chers collègues je vous propose de de
commencer cette deuxe réunion de de la
commission de la défense puisqu'on étit
hier réuni pour le la remise du rapport
sur le les exports de matériel de guerre
les matériels les biens à double usage
mais c'est notre première sur ce format
100 % commission j'espère que tout le
monde a passé une de bonnes vacances et
que tout le monde revient revigorer pour
pour entamer le travail de cette deuxe
année euh vous avez vu que l'été a été
l'occasion de de faire plusieurs
modifications au sein de notre
commission vous avez notamment remarqué
les nouvelles décorations la nouvelle
carte conformément à ce qui avait été vu
au bureau et que par ailleurs vous avez
reçu également le bilan d'activité de de
l'année 1 qui permet de faire le de
dresser à la fois le bilan et bien
entendu maintenant il faut qu'on se
projette également vers l'année 2 vers
les
projets il y aura une réunion du bureau
mardi prochain à ce à ce sujetl pour
discuter amender sur la base d'une
proposition de de feuille de route que
j'ai transmis aux membres du du bureau
pour savoir ce qui nous occupera notre
stratégie ce qui nous occupera au cours
de de l'année 2 et puis vous avez sans
doute reçu également l'invitation pour
ce qui sera un pe convivial de rentrer
mardi soir prochain à 19h30 à l'issue de
l'audition du ministre dans le cadre du
du projet lo de finances je peux vous
dire que tout le monde a bien répondu
parmi les autorités militaires
ministérielles ù l'ensemble de
l'écosystème de défense que ce soit les
f tank les journalistes les attachés de
défense et donc je pense qu'on aura un
événement assez important mardi prochain
voilà euh sans plus attendre je vous
propose de passer à notre audition
messieurs les les
directeurs pour cette 2è année donc
c'est quasiment une tradition nous
ouvrons nos nos travaux par l'audition
des dirigeants des trois principaux Fing
tank français qui contribue à éclairer
notre réflexion sur les enjeux
stratégiques auxquels doit faire face
notre notre pays je souhaite donc la
bienvenue à Monsieur Pascal Boniface
directeur de l'ERIS l'Institut des
relations internationales et
stratégiques auteur de nombreux ouvrages
de de géopolitique parmi lesquels le
désormais classique comprendre le monde
qui je crois on est à s à sa 7e édition
et plus récemment le livre guerre en
Ukraine l'onde de choc
géopolitique Monsieur Thomas gomard
directeur de l'IFRI l'Institut français
des relations internationales don
dernier ouvrage est consacré à ce que
vous appelez les ambitions inavouées ce
que préparent les les grandes puissances
et enfin Monsieur Bruno tertray
directeur adjoint de la frs la Fondation
pour la recherche stratégique qui a non
notamment consacré de nombreux travaux à
l'arme nucléaire et qui s'apprête à
publier début octobre je crois que c'est
plus un secret la guerre des mondes le
retour de la géopolitique et le choc des
empire un grand merci messieurs de vous
être rendu disponible pour nous
présenter votre vision actualisée du
monde et nous aider à établir les bons
diagnostics qui nous permettront euh de
mettre en avant de travailler sur
différents points de de vigilance mes
chers collègues je vous rappelle qu'on
avait eu juste avant l'été l'audition
euh du DRM notamment sur la situation en
Ukraine et euh avant d'entamer le cycle
budgétaire dans le cadre du projet de
votre finance 2024 il me semble que
cette audition présente plusieurs
intérêts euh le premier bien entendu la
menace dicte le format d'armée aussi il
nous faut comprendre la géopolitique et
ses ambiguïtés pour nous assurer des
bons choix capacitaires dans la
déclinaison de la loi de programmation
militaire deuxièmement cette lecture du
monde ne doit pas être biaisée ou
influencée et c'est pourquoi votre
parole particulièrement libre nous
intéresse troisièmement elle démontre
clairement la nécessité pour la
commission pour notre commission et plus
largement pour l'écosy système de de
défense l'importance de la recherche
dans l'élaboration de nos stratégies si
les relations internationales et tout
particulièrement les question de défense
ressort principalement sous la 5e
République de l'exécutif et notamment du
du président de la République nous
estimons que cette commission a
effectivement un rôle important à jouer
en aidant à poser les bons débats en
soulevant les bonnes questions et cela
est particulièrement vrai au lendemain
du vote de la nouvelle LPM en s'assurant
dans la durée de la cohérence et de la
pertinence des choix effectif tué et de
la mise en œuvre des engagements retenus
voilà sans plus tarder je vais
maintenant céder la la parole à aux
trois directeurs qui sont ici présents
Monsieur Pascal Bonifas je vous propose
de commencer vous avez la parole
pour merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
bonjour tout d'abord merci pour cette
initiative je crois que jamais les
relations entre la commission de la
défense et des forces armées et les
différents Fing tank n'a été aussi
profonde riche nourrie réciproque et
pour nous c'est un plaisir et un honneur
que d'être là et de pouvoir échanger
avec vous on peut dire qu'il y a
aujourd'hui dans l'ordre mondial trois
grandes coupures qui s'imposent à nous
la première c'est une coupure durable
longue entre la Russie et le monde
occidental du fait de la guerre lancée
par Vladimir Poutine contre l'Ukraine en
février il n'y aura pas de relation
normalisée entre la Russie et les
Occidentaux des sanctions ont été prises
elles se sont accumulées on strint et on
peut dire que l'état des relations entre
la Russie et le monde occidental revient
un peu à ce qu'il était dans les années
50 du temps de l'Union soviétique et je
dirais au pire de l'Union soviétique
Poutine restera peut-être au pouvoir il
faudra toujours peut-être un jour parler
avec lui mais il ne pourra pas y avoir
de normalisation des relations avec la
Russie tant qu'il sera au pouvoir du
fait que l'horreur de l'effroid du choc
qu' a créé la guerre en Raine non
seulement chez nos dirigeants mais
également dans notre opinion publique la
deuxième coupure elle n'est pas née avec
la guerre en Ukraine mais cette guerre
lui a donné une importance plus grande
elle l'a stimulé elle l'a amplifié c'est
la coupure entre ce qu'on appelle the
West versus the rest alors il y a
beaucoup de débats sur la façon de
définir le the West on le définit très
facilement ce sont les pays membres de
l'OTAN auquel on peut ajouter
l'Australie la Nouvelle-Zélande et puis
des pays qui qui sont culturellement
asiatiques mais stratégiquement
occidentaux comme la Corée du Sud et le
Japon et le reste est plus difficile à
définir parce que on parle du Sud global
des Sud global c'est tous les autres
c'est tous les autres n'ont pas de but
commun forcément ils nont pas toujours
de projets commun mais ils ont un rejet
commun le rejet commun c'est un monde
dominé par le monde occidental et ça ils
n'en veulent plus ils n'en veulent plus
de façon très différente et on ne peut
pas dire qu'il y a une coupure entre
démocratie et dictature puisque dans les
pays du reste il y a des démocraties le
Brésil l'Inde même si c'est une
démocratie imparfaite pour les musulmans
l'Afrique du Sud même s'il y a des
corruptions qui peuvent entacher la
démocratie et de nombreux autres pays
mais en tous les cas on voit que sur la
guerre en Ukraine qui reste pour nous
notre horison stratégique le plus
important ils n'ont pas la même
appréciation tous les plans de paix qui
sont venus du sud Brésil Indonésie Chine
pays africains mettent comme préalable
le cesser le feu alors que nous mettons
comme préalable la reconquête par
l'Ukraine de son intégrité territoriale
et donc les pays du Sud ont pour urgence
de dire que il faut cesser les combats
cesser la guerre parce qu'ils en payent
le prix sans en être responsable alors
que nous nous pensons qu'il ne faut pas
que l'agresseur soit récompensé par un
gain territorial et et donc aucun de ces
pays n'a pris de sanctions la plupart
ont condamné l'agression russe aux
Nations unies dans trois votes
différents 140 d'entre eux mais aucun de
ces pays n'a pris des sanctions parce
que tout simplement ils estiment qu'ils
n'ont pas été assz associés à la
décision de prendre des sanctions ils
estiment que ces sanctions les
sanctionneraient eux-mêmes et qu'ils
n'en ont pas les moyens et ils estiment
que ce n'est pas aux Occidentaux de
déterminer quelle sera leur politique et
donc là il y a un changement important
c'est l'émergence ces pays en plus ils
ont une sorte de club qui n'est pas une
alliance mais un club qui prend de
l'importance qui est les brixs comme l'a
remarqué le président de la République
devant le discours face aux ambassadeur
le 30 août il y a une trentaine de
demandes d'adhésion au brick il n'y a
pas de demande de rejoindre le G20 donc
on voit bien qu'il y a un club qui a le
vent en poupe et d'autres qui le sont
pas ceci étant les bricks ne sont pas
une alliance les différents pays ont des
intérêts différents tous n'ont pas la
même relation avec le monde occidental
ce qu'ils ont en commun en tous les cas
c'est la volonté de se débarrasser du
dollar ou du moins de diminuer le rôle
du dollar comme monnaie d'échange
internationale justement pour échapper
aux sanctions et il est à ce qui unit
aussi ces pays c'est le rejet des
sanctions parce qu'ils estiment qu'ils
en ont tous été victimes ou qu'ils sont
tous menacés dans être victime que la
les sanctions sont une politique
occidentale qui souvent s'adresse à eux
et donc dans le rejet des sanctions il y
a aussi le fait qu'ils peuvent être
concernés par cela et qu'il refuse cette
conception occidentale de dire que
lorsqu'on n'est pas d'accord avec un
pays on le sanctionne et les sanction
c'est toujours du nord au sud ce n'est
jamais l'inverse et donc il travaille un
peu à dolariser l'économie
internationale c'est un objectif
lointain qui n'est pas prêt d'être
atteint mais en tout les cas ils y
travaillent et maintenant l'Arabie
saoudit vend du pétrole en riminbi à la
Chine et les éirarunis en roupi à l'Inde
et la Russie et la Chine travaillent en
monnaie commune l'Argentine et le Brésil
veulent travailler travailler à créer
une monnaie commune donc on voit que les
choses changent l'arrivée de l'Arabie
saudide dans les Brix a un effet
important puisque ça renforce le
caractère énergie de cette cette
alliance et ça montre surtout que le
PACT du quinsi n'a plus
d'existence et que l'Arabie saudite veut
se défaire d'une relation unique de
dépendance à l'égard des États-Unis les
Saoudiens ont refusé d'augmenter leur
production de pétrole à la demande des
Américains alors que le président
américain s'était spécialement déplacé à
Riad pour le demander ils l'ont même
réduite par la suite donc montrant un
peu que ils ont une option de rechange
qui est la Chine et que donc ils ne ils
ne veulent plus obéir de façon
automatique aux Américains mais dans ce
reste il y a en fait trois stratégies il
y a une stratégie de confrontation
directe avec l'Occident la Russie la
Corée du Nord l'Iran qui sont en
confrontation directe avec les
Occidentaux un pays un peu à part la
Chine qui d'ailleurs est à la fois un
atout pour les bricks en même temps un
handicap puisque le poids de la Chine au
sein des bricks est tellement grand que
cela peut effrayer d'autres membres et
que ça pose un problème de équilibre au
sein de ce club mais la Chine ne veut
pas couper les relations avec le monde
occidental c'est pour cela qu'elle ne
fournit pas directement et massivement
des armes à la Russie et que elle veut
toujours avoir accès à nos marchés avoir
accès à aux échang économique avec nous
tout en et bien en fait tout en visant à
la suprématie mondiale ou au premier
poste mondial pour remplacer les
États-Unis et vous avez des pays qui
sont dans une autre configuration c'est
le Brésil et l'Inde par exemple qui eux
jouent vraiment une politique
d'équilibre entre l'Occident et le reste
et qui donc ni ne ni ne veulent se
couper de la Russie mais en même temps
veulent être des partenaires du monde
occidental parce qu'ils en ont besoin
pour leur développement économique et en
fait on peut dire que le le motif indien
par exemple c'est de dire que l'intérêt
national de l'Inde qui s'exerce par le
multi-alignement c'est le développement
économique si le développement
économique peut être atteint par des
liens avec la Russie très bien s'il peut
être atteint par des liens avec les très
bien et si on doit faire les deux pour
réussir le développement économique on
fera les deux donc c'est quelque chose
qui sera suivi et on aura du mal à
revenir là-dessus et la troisième
coupure vous la connaissez classiquement
c'est celle entre pour la suprématie
mondiale la la place de numéro 1 entre
la Chine et les États-Unis la Chine
connaît une panne économique elle a du
mal à sortir du covid mais je ne suis
pas sûr que l'on puisse parier sur une
stanation durable et longue de la Chine
ni sur l'éclatement d'une bule
spéculative comme certains le disent et
en tous les cas on voit aussi que par
rapport à la guerre en Ukraine la Chine
ne souhaite pas la défaite de la Russie
et encore moins son effondrement qui
créerait un vide stratégique ce que les
Américains ne souhaitent pas d'ailleurs
non plus c'est peut-être un des rares
point d'accord qu'ils ont un pays avec
des milliers d'armes nucléaires sur 11
fuseaux horaires c'est pas le bon droit
pour créer un vide mais elle ne souhaite
pas une victoire occidentale et elle
fera tout pour l'éviter je crois qu'au
départ cette gure en Ukraine gênait la
Chine qui n'était pas très content de
l'attitude de la Russie parce que ça
augmentait le prix des matières
premières alimentaires et le prix
d'énergie qui sont les deux principaux
postes d'exportation d'importation
pardon de la Chine mais aujourd'hui et
et et par ailleurs l'épisode Prigogine a
montré à la Chine que
déjà il y avait une sorte de mépris pour
l'URS de la vision de Gorbatchev mais un
pays dans lequel des milices peuvent
contester le pouvoir central ça ne
risque pas d'arriver en Chine et le
parti commande toujours au fusil en
Chine commande également d'ailleurs au
batx et donc ceci est vu quand même avec
beaucoup de stupéfaction il prouve que
la Russie et que Poutine ne tient pas
vraiment sa boutique mais aujourd'hui le
temps long de la guerre en Ukraine joue
pour la Chine puisque la Chine peut
aller un peu partout dans justement le
wouest CE sur quoi elle mise le reste
plutôt ce sur quoi mise pour dire
regardez la guerre continue vous en
souffrez c'est de la faute des
Américains qui alimentent la guerre en
livrant des armes à l'Ukraine s'il
cessait la guerre s'arrêterait tout de
suite et vos problèmes économiques
cesseraiit immédiatement nous nous
sommes pour la paix malheureusement nous
ne sommes pas écoutés et les différents
plans de paix qui ont été envoyés ne
sont pas pris en compte et donc vous
souffrez du fait que l'Occident veut
mener par Ukraine interposer une guerre
à la Russie dont vous faites les frais
et c'est un discours qui reçoit une
certaine audience l'autonomie
stratégique européenne qui est
l'objectif traditionnel l'ADN
géopolitique de la France depuis le
début de la 5e avons-le j'en suis un
partisan est en panne parce que nos
partenaires européens ne veulent plus
entendre parler ils pensent que seul les
États-Unis peut nous défendre contre la
menace militaire russe mais en même
temps la menace militaire russe les
Russes n'étant pas CAPAES de conquérir
l'Ukraine je les vois mal arriver à
Varsovie ou à Berlin on pourrait disons
peut-être regarder ça d'un œil attentif
et puis il y a des échances politiques
aux États-Unis qui pourraient accélérer
la réflexion donc je peux pense peut
dire que l'autonomie strraique
européenne elle est pas en état de mort
cérébrale elle est pas braand dead mais
elle est en mauvais état mais elle peut
très bien ressurgir en fonction
d'événements qui nous échappent dont
notamment les élections aux États-Unis
sont quand même un élément important un
sujet d'inquiétude et moi qui travaille
depuis très longtemps sur l'entente
franco-allemande c'est l'état de nos
relations avec l'Allemagne
euh peut-être certains d'entre vous ont
profité de l'été pour lire le livre de
mémoire de Claude Martin qui est un pavé
900 pages mais quand même quelqu'un qui
a été ne ans ambassadeur en Allemagne
qui est germanophone mais surtout
germanophile qui est parmi nos
diplomates celui qui a le plus plaidé
pour un dialogue suivi avec l'Allemagne
dresse un constat amerre déçu de
l'attitude de l'Allemagne à notre égard
depuis assez longtemps et en disant
l'Allemagne joue son Inter naational et
des fois elle pense que interérêt
national diffèrent Diver ou est
contraire à l'international français et
nous n'en tenons pas compte nous parlons
encore du couple franco- allemand les
Allemands jamais n'en parlent et il n'y
a pas vraiment de couple et donc un défi
c'est comment renouer un fil avec
l'Allemagne qui nous est indispensable
mais sans le faire aux conditions des
Allemagnes comment faire respecter nos
intérêts par rapport à un partenaire de
vu devenu rétissent et qui ne nous
écoute plus beaucoup y compris sur les
questions de défense deuxème point
d'inquiétude c'est l'industrie de
défense elle est centrale elle est
capitale pour notre indépendance la 5e
République s'en est dotée justement pour
avoir l'indépendance d' de décision et
indispensable et là on voit que il y a
quand même des menaces 78 % des
acquisitions d'armes euh des pays
européens ont été faites à l'étranger
enfin en dehors de l'Europe 63 % l'an
dernier 63 % aux États-Unis donc en fait
on a à la fois une augmentation très
nette des dépenses d'armement ce qui
bien sûr va muscler le dispositif mais
tout ceci est quand même au profit de
l'industrie américaine pour 103 % de
l'industrie sud-coréenne israélienne
pour le reste et on risque tout d'un
coup quand les budgets ont été consommés
de dire bah voilà on a les équipements
maintenant les équipements européens
sont prêts mais on est déjà équipé donc
on n plus vraiment ce besoin c'est
quelqu quelque chose qui est vraiment
important trisème point d'inquiétude bah
c'est l'Afrique je pense que sera
difficile d'avoir une nouvelle
dégradation des relations tellement
elles sont
dégradées peut-être alors pour l'Afrique
francophone parce que dans le reste de
l'Afrique on a pas de problème on a pas
de problème au Kenya on n pas de
problème au zambique on a pas de
problème en Afrique du Sud on n pas de
problème dans l'Afrique anglophone et
lusophone c'est un peu le paradoxe et
peut-être là bon un ancien ministre des
Affaires étrangères et de la défense
disit parlait de façon petit un peu
méprisante des experts autoproclamés il
y a quand même des études universitaires
qui mettent en avant quand même le
danger d'une coupure entre les esprits
africains entre les sociétés civiles
africaines et la France des signaux
d'alerte ont été
envoyés une chercheuse de chez nous
avait dit a un risque de coup d'État au
nigerre il y a un an et cetera et donc
c'est peut-être là justement que la
proximité que vous mettez en place
monsieur le Président entre les Fing
tank et la représentant parlementaire
pourrait être utile par rapport
peut-être à des systèmes gouvernementaux
qui euh restent un peu sur des schémas
acquis merci monsieur le directeur pour
ce panorama très très complet la parole
est à Thomas gomard directeur de l'IFRI
directeur adjoint je crois ou directeur
je sais plus vous nous
préciserez merci monsieur le Président
pour votre invitation Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires je très
heureux de de vous retrouver toujours un
honneur pour moi de représenter l'ifprit
devant votre votre commission alors les
instructions qui nous ont été donné pour
cette session par Monsieur Lebau était
une carte blanche c'est-à-dire de faire
ce que l'on souhaitait faire je vais
essayer de faire une carte blanche avec
un chiffre une image et une citation
pour pour
commencer le chiffre c'est 2240
milliards de dollars qui est le montant
de la la dépense militaire globale en
2022 il était pour mémoire de 1140
milliards de dollars en
20001 en une génération la dépense
militaire globale a
doublé l'image c'est celle du capitaine
Ibrahim traouret beret rouge vissé sur
la tête à la tribune du 2e sommet
russie-afrique à Saint-Pétersbourg
déclarant je cite nos grands par ont été
déportés pour sauver l'Europe c'était
pas avec leur consentement fin de
citation la citation c'est celle
extraite du long discours du président
de la République aux ambassadrices et
aux ambassadeurs je cite la Russie ne
doit ne peut pardon ni ne doit gagner
cette guerre parce qu'alors ce serait
l'instabilité sur le sol européen et
parce qu'alors ce serait la fin de toute
confiance dans les principes du droit
international je crois que ce chiffre
cette image et cette situation devrait
nous convaincre de la gravité de la
situation et je partage avec Jean-Marie
Gueno malheureusement le constat que les
opinions occidentales ont aujourd'hui le
spectacle de la guerre mais non la
guerre
elle-même au fond elle mène un combat à
distance sans croire vraiment à la
guerre et je crois que nous avons tort
de nous considérer à l'écart
je vais essayer de l'illustrer en trois
volets d'abord en
retraçant des grandes trajectoires
ensuite en vous proposant un focus sur
la guerre d'Ukraine et enfin en
finissant par les enjeux qui de mon
point de vue sont devant nous pour la
France les grandes trajectoires c'est
d'abord l'évolution de la relation entre
la Chine et les États-Unis une rivalité
stratégique qu'on pourrait résumer ainsi
dans le domaine économque omique
découpage impossible mais coopération
improbable nous sommes face à une
arsenalisation des échanges aussi bien
du côté américain que du côté chinois et
nous sommes face à une situation tout à
fait inédite où les deux premières
économies mondiales sont devenu
protectionnistes et contournent
ouvertement l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce l'administration Biden a pris
un train de décision extrêmement
structur
qui rappelle la centralité des
États-Unis à partir du moment où ils ont
une administration
cohérente premièrement février 2022 le
gel des avoirs de la Banque centrale de
Russie août 2022 le paquet législatifs
pour des investissements publics massifs
à travers l'infrastructure investment
job acts chips and science Act inflation
reduction Act octobre 2022 le contrôle
des exportations technologiques vers la
Chine et plus récemment en août 2023 la
restriction des investissements
technologiques en Chine avec toutes
leurs conséquences
juridique du côté chinois nous avons été
surpris par la réouverture du jour au
lendemain décidé par le Président si le
20e congrès qui n'est pas celui de la
décanalisation de la reprise en main
caractérisé du système
chinois et également le recours à des
sanctions de plus en plus prononcé la
part de la Chine vis-à-vis de certains
pays en particulier d'un pays comme la
Lituanie deuxè trajectoire c'est celle
de l'Union européenne face à la guerre
d'Ukraine comme vous le savez la Russie
a longtemps été un sujet clivant au sein
de l'Union européenne entre eux pour
simplifier à outrance des pays d'Europe
du Nord et de l'Est favorable à une
position de force et des pays d'Europe
de l'Ouest et du Sud plus favorabl à une
coopération
ce clivage a produit un message
politique brouillé après l'annexion de
la Crimée considéré au fond comme un
incident sans importance dans certaines
capitales dont la nôtre avec quelques
sanctions et des tentative de
réengagement pour reprendre le terme à
la mode qui a été un échec réengagement
tenté également par les États-Unis je le
rappelle sous l'administration
Obama en revanche l'Union européenne
à la fois créer et maintenir une unité
dans le soutien à l'Ukraine avec la
constitution de nouveaux instruments je
pense par exemple au Fond Européen de
défense mais l'Union européenne est dans
une situation d'échec stratégique dans
la mesure où sa politique de voisinage
qui visait six pays la Biélorussie la
Moldavie l'Ukraine la Georgie l'Arménie
et l'Azerbaïdjan est une politique au
fond où nous avons aujourd'hui six
conflits dans chacun de ces pays
avec le dernier en date enfin qui
réactivé celui entre l'Azerbaïdjan et
l'Arménie et la question de savoir si
l'Azerbaïdjan va s'arrêter là si la
réponse était négative quelle serait
l'attitude des Européens ça c'est à mon
avis un sujet 2023 2024 j'ajoute un
autre sujet 2024 à mon avis peut-être là
aussi pour l'effort d'anticipation qui
doit être le nôre la perspective de
l'élection américaine très attendue à
Moscou puisque'au fond les calculs
plus ou moins pertinent sont les
suivants un candidat républicain
pourrait remettre en cause le soutien à
l'Ukraine je pense que c'est la grande
question en fait pour les Européens si
ils considèrent qu'ils ont une autonomie
stratégique quelle devrait être
l'attitude par rapport à l'Ukraine en
cas de réduction ou d'arrêt du soutien
américain à l'Ukraine c'est sur cette
question que l'autonomie stratégique
européenne se décidera
3è trajectoire c'est évidemment Pascal
Boniface en a dit un mot l'évolution du
du reste avec ces différents formats le
format BRI brick pardon élargi à si
nouveaux membres à partir du 1er janvier
2024 qui correspond à un succès
diplomatique de la Chine le format G20
qui correspond un succès diplomatique de
l'Inde c'est ont fait l'objet de
nombreux commentaires je voudrais juste
souligner le rôle à mon avis de plus en
plus important de puissance moyenne au
premier rant desquels figure l'Inde
Israël la Turquie l'Arabie Saoudite et
les Émirats qui cherchent à exploiter
leur neutralité pour au fond tirer des
bénéfices des deux camps créés par la
guerre d'Ukraine la Turquie vend des
armes à l'Ukraine mais négocie un accord
séréalier qui n'a pas été renouvelé
comme vous le savez l' achète ces armes
à la Russie et du Pétrole bradé deux
exemples parmi
d'autres donc c'est trois ces trois
grandes trajectoires États-Unis Chine
Europe et puis le
reste se font effectivement aussi dans
une situation d'accélération de la
dégradation environnementale sur la sur
laquelle je pourrais revenir mais qui
mettent les enjeux de l'agenda dit
global en haut des priorités devrait
mettre les enjeux de l'agenda
global en haut des
priorités le deuxème volet c'est la
guerre d'Ukraine qui a commencé je le
rappelle toujours en février 2014 par
l'annexion de la
Crimée elle a désormais une dimension
globale qui s'explique par trois
éléments principaux le premier c'est que
elle elle oppose deux puissances
agricooles la Russie et l'Ukraine
représenté avant février 202 2 30 % des
exportations mondiales de blé en 2016 je
le rappelle la Russie est devenue le
premier exportateur mondial de de blé et
au fond vous avez désormais une
instrumentalisation tout à fait assumée
par la
Russie des approvisionnements
alimentaires et du thème de la famine le
thème de la famine redevient un un sujet
dans le discours politique de la Russie
à la fois sur le plan interne et sur le
plan externe l'ambition de la Russie
c'est déévincer l'Ukraine du marché du
blé et c'est d'attaquer à terme des
positions établies comme cell des
États-Unis et de l'Union européenne sur
un certain nombre de marchés en
particulier
l'Algérie deuxè point de la dimension
globale la rupture de la relation
énergétique entre la Russie et l'Union
européenne qui a des conséquences
directes pour le modèle économique
allemand qui oblige les Européens à
diversifier leurs approvisionnement et
qui crée un choc énergétique dont
l'inflation euh est un des
reflets trème point de cette dimension
globale c'est que nous sommes avec la
guerre d'Ukraine retourné dans une
ambiance nucléaire
l'agitation de la rhétorique nucléaire
par le kremelin est présente depuis
février 2022 et j'insiste sur ce point
parce que le
désintérêt des du reste pour cette
guerre d'Ukraine qui est effectivement
régulièrement souligné peut-être corrigé
par cette dimension nucléaire
c'est-à-dire que quand on explique à ces
pays qu'en réalité nous sommes face à
une crise nucléaire avec un membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité
puissance doté qui exerce un chantage
nucléaire il y a là évidemment un sujet
également pour
eux les objectifs de la Russie de
Vladimir Poutine reste inchangé il
s'agit premièrement d'asservir
l'Ukraine deuxièmement de reconstituer
ce que la Russie appelle le Kemlin
appelle Novaya alasia c'est-à-dire ces
terre
d'Empire et
enfin d'essayer d'abattre ce que le
président Poutine appelle l'Occident
collectif en insistant sur une cassant
au fond la relation transatlantique et
en suscitant des divisions entre
Européens la Russie comme vous le savez
se présente désormais comme un état
civilisation et pour l'illustrer je
voudrais citer le président Poutine en
février
2023 je cite des millions de gens en
Occident se rendent bien compte qu'on
les mène droit vers une catastrophe
spirituelle les élites pour le dire en
toute honnêteté deviennent complètement
foles et ce mal ne me semble pas curable
ceci dit c'est leur problème ça les
regarde de notre côté le devoir que nous
avons est celui de protéger nos enfants
et c'est bien ce que nous avons
l'intention de faire protéger nos
enfants de la dégradation et de la
dégénérescence fin de
citation l'Ukraine quant à elle sent
très bien que la sympathie à son égard
est en train de s'éroder et sent très
bien la versatilité des opinions
occidentales cette prise de conscience a
notamment été exprimée dans les
différentes prises de parole du
président zéinsk récemment je cite en
septembre 2023 à l'Assemblée générale
des Nations unies alors que les armes
nucléairirees restent en place la
destruction massive prend de l'ampleur
l'agresseur a recours à de nombreuses
autres armes qui sont utilisé non
seulement contre notre pays mais aussi
contre les
vôtres les objectifs de l'Ukraine sont
premièrement de recouvrer sa
souveraineté en ciblant prioritairement
la
Crimée de se doter d'une industrie
d'armement pour gagner en autonomie en
cas d'arrêt du soutien occidental et
évidemment de rejoindre
l'OTAN et l'Union
européenne alors dans ce contexte
général 3è et dernière partie quels sont
les les enjeux pour pour la France dans
une perspective de de court et de de
moyen terme qui qui vous
occupe premièrement évidemment la
situation intérieure de notre pays sur
laquelle je vais pas faire de long de
long développement mais la situation
d'appauvrissement qui est la nôtre
comptenu de l'état de notre commerce
extérieur la situation provoquée par
l'inflation et notre niveau de dette qui
correspond un niveau de Guer un niveau
de dette de guerre alors que nous ne
sommes pas en guerre 3000 milliards et
au fond ce qui est en jeu c'est la
compétitivité de notre appareil
productif compétitivité s'inscrivant
dans la compé compétitivité européenne
pardon laquelle s'est très sévèrement
dégradée par rapport à celle des
États-Unis deuxème enjeu c'est et vous y
avez consacré nbre important d'heure je
crois la mise en œuvre de la loi de
programmation militaire
2024-2030 qui dans sa lecture
géopolitique j'ai eu l'occasion de
l'exprimer devant une autre commission
euh est un Paris que je qualifieraiis
d'assez optimiste sur le maintien d'un
état de paix que nous souhaitons tous
mais qui pourrait être évidemment
perturbé par un certain nombre
d'événements la LPM à mon avis dans sa
mise en œuvre doit veiller à garantir
l'endurance stratégique dans laquelle
nous sommes engagés à cause de la guerre
d'Ukraine les éventuels effets de la
dégradation inévitable de la situation
sécuritaire en Afrique
subsaharienne et puis évidemment des
enjeux liés à la protection de nos
dromcom entre autres
choses 3è et dernier
point l'enjeu je pense pour la France
c'est aussi notre positionnement au sein
de nos alliances qui de mon point de vue
doivent être chéris en période de gros
temps
géopolitique au sein de l'Union
européenne je l'ai dit l'Allemagne est
en train de réinventer son modèle euh
géoéconomique et je pense que la France
va devoir réinventer son modèle
géopolitique comp tenu des événements
récents en
Afrique au fond pour reprendre la
formule de Guillaume Garnier dans un
dans une étude récente de l'ifrice sur
la place de la France dans l'OTAN nous
sommes face à une poupée gigogne de
sécurité
la grande poupée c'est
l'alliance la poupée intermédiaire c'est
le pilier
européen et la petite poupée ça reste
les armées
françaises et donc c'est la cohérence et
le maintien de cette poupée gigogne dans
un contexte de grande difficultés
franco-allemande qui à mon avis doit
nous occuper je finirai monsieur le
Président cette présentation avec un un
dernier mot en disant que de mon point
de vue nous sommes face à une
accélération qui nous est défavorable
car nous sommes une puissance du
statutco et que nous devons à mon sens
nous préparer à des ajustements brutaux
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci Monsieur le le directeur pour ce
panorama également très complet et enfin
pour terminer la parole est à Monsieur
Bruno tertray directeur adjoint de la
frs merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés ce que je vais
vous dire n'est pas orthogonal avec ce
que viennent de dire mes mes de
collègues je serai donc peut-être un
petit peu un peu plus bref mais en tout
cas j'ai quelques compléments à apporter
et peut-être une articulation légèrement
différente des sujet qui qui nous
préoccupe j'ai quatre tendances
militaires six tendances régionales avec
des ruptures possibles et pour terminer
quatre réflexions Brè sur les choix les
choix de la France les tendances
militaires ça a été dit tout à l'heure
l'accroissement des dépenses de défense
mondiale est un phénomène eff
effectivement extrêmement impressionnant
depuis 2015 nous sommes entrés au niveau
mondial dans un 2uxè cycle de de
réarmement après celui qui avait
commencé à la toute fin des années 1990
environ de 1998 il concerne bien sûr à
la fois les puissances majeur et les
puissances émergentes deuxième tendance
la prolifération des des matériels et
des équipements à relativement bas cout
mais à efficacité importante on le voit
tous les jours sur le champ de bataille
ukrainien ainsi bien sûr que les
technologies dites dual au prix d'une
formule facile qui a peut-être déjà été
trouvé par d'autres je parlerai d'une du
pouvoir égalisateur de l'électron ou
peut-être surtout de l'octé je suis sûr
que cette formule a déjà été inventée
donc je ne je je je ne prétends pas en
être en être le seul le seul dépositaire
troisème tendance plus positive c'est
que on parle un peu moins de la
prolifération de ce qu'on appelle les
armes de destruction massive expression
impropre mais au enne chimique
biologique et
nucléaire hormis le cas de la Corée du
Nord qui n'est plus une crise de
prolifération mais un problème de de
dissuasion et le cas de l'Iran sur
lequel je reviendrai il n'y a pas et je
pense qu'il n'y aura pas de nouvelles
vague de
prolifération nucléaire dans les années
qui viennent la prolifération nucléaire
est contenue enfin la dernière qui
mérite d'être rappelée même si si c'est
une évidence le nonemploi de l'arme
nucléaire est tout de même année après
année une bonne nouvelle et je pense
pense que sur la Russie je l'ai dit dès
la fin février 2022 je continue à le
penser même si la rhtorique débridée en
provenant de certains sèces moscovite
parfois très proche du pouvoir est un
motif d'inquiétude pour de multiples
raisons la politique nucléaire russe la
politique de dissuasion russe le
comportement officiel du kremelin et des
armées russes sur la question nucléaire
et plutôt un plutôt rassurant je le
répète je l'assume et je ne suis pas
connu pour être un ami des dirigeants du
cremelin sur les les tendances
régionales je commence bien sûr la la
première je commence bien sûr par par
l'Ukraine un conflit probablement
durable avec une Russie désormais entrée
en économie de guerre si vous voulez
voir ce qu'est un pays économie de
guerre c'est pas la France he c'est la
Russie là c'est vraiment un pays qui
s'installe dans une économie de guerre à
tout point de vue mais au risque de la
facilité je vous dirais que ça peut
durer 3 mois 3 ans ou 30 ans 3 mois
c'estement une formule de cile bien sûr
mais
l'effondrement de l'armée de l'agresseur
c'est quelque chose qu'on a vu qu'on a
déjà vu dans l'histoire ça peut aller
assez rapidement on nen prend pas le
chemin tout de suite mais ce n'est pas
parce que le dispositif défensif rus
résiste extrêmement bien qu'il ne peut
pas à un moment s'effondrer cela peut se
produire dans en horizon relativement
proche 3 ans c'est pour dire que c'est
un conflit c'est pour rappeler bien sûr
c'est un conflit qui malheureusement
nous rappelle à nous Européens le
premier conflit mondial et 30 ans c'est
le scénario coréen c'est-à-dire un un
moment où le conflit à force de cesser
le feu de division plus ou moins
sanctionné et accepté s'installe en fait
dans une absence de de règlement de
règlement définitifs ce qui pourrait
faire changer les choses outre
l'improbable mais toujours possible
effondrement total de la de l'armée
russe c'est bien sûr ça a été dit par
mes par mes collègues l'arrivée de
Donald Trump même si les Ukrainiens
comme ça a été dit également y pensent
s'y préparent et surtout ça signifierait
pas mécaniquement l'arrêt de toute aide
militaire américaine immédiatement des
l'élection il y aurait un temps
d'adaptation et c'est là
qu'effectivement pour les Européens ça
sera un moment très important deuxième
tendance la radicalisation du pouvoir
russe et ce n'est pas forcément nous qui
poussons la Russie dans les bras de la
Chine c'est aussi un choix de la Russie
un choix assumé par Vladimir Poutine
depuis très longtemps mais évidemment le
conflit en Ukraine et la réaction
occidentale contribu bien sûr à ce
rapprochement qui n'est pas une alliance
qui n' sera qui n'en sera pas une mais
qui en est pas moins de plus en plus de
plus en plus solide je partage le
diagnosticque qui a été fait tout à
l'heure nous ne pouvons pas nous
européens nous ne pourrons pas avoir
c'est terminé euh nous ne pourrons plus
avoir de relations normales avec la
Russie depuis avant longtemps on pourra
peut-être euh je dire à échéance humaine
en avoir mais il est trop tard pour en
avoir rapidement voilà pour retrouver
des relations total totalement normales
euh avec la Russie euh autrement dit
pour en revenir à la situation de près
près 2014 voire près euh 2022 euh 3è
point c'est la pérenité de l'OTAN et la
pérenité de la présence américaine euh
avec des Européens et ça a été dit tout
à l'heure effectivement euh euh qui
s'efforce d'acheter la protection
américaine avec des acquisitions
extrêmement importantes depuis euh
depuis 2 ans euh les euh nos alliés
européens estiment que acheter du F3 5
c'est se protéger contre une présidence
Trump à mon avis il se trompe mais en
tout cas c'est comme ça que cela
fonctionne il faut il faut en prendre
acte sur l'hypothèse Trump ou Trump
équivalent nous ne sommes toujours pas
prêts on y pense on y pense à Bruxelles
on y pense à Paris on y pense à Berlin
un petit peu moins mais dans certains
pays y compris celui que je viens de
mentionner on est on est quand même très
facilement dans le
dénis le souvenir de la première
présidence Trump pendant laquelle
finalement on a on s'est débrouillé et
souvent mis en exerg pour se rassurer ce
qui à mon sens est une erreur donc on y
pense mais pas assez parce que je pense
que si vous avez avec d'autres que si
vous avez aimé la première présidente
vous adorerez la deuxième ça n'aura rien
à voir ça n'aura rien à voir et ce sera
effectivement l'heure de vérité pour
pour les Européens
4e 4e tendance bien sûr les les tensions
sino-américaine croissante avec assez
peu d'espoir de voir les choses se
s'améliorer c'est structurant bien sûr
pour les relations internationales
découplages impossibles des risquage
probable je crois qu'on est tout tous
d'accord sur le sujet avec la toujours
la rupture possible de l'invasion de
Taïwan même si ça n'est pas un scénario
probable aujourd'hui voilà on peut une
manière raisonnable de de dire les
choses 5è tendance un Iran qui est
arrivé désormais à ce qu'on appelle même
s'il y a pas de définition officielle le
seuil nucléaire c'est-à-dire qu'il peut
avoir suffisamment de matière
nucléaire matière ficile en quelques
jours en quelques jours ce qui est
rassurant toutefois c'est qu'il n'y ait
pas en tout cas je ne connais pas
d'indication comme quoi l'Iran aurait
repris ses travaux dit de militarisation
c'est-à-dire de d'études de fabrication
de la charge qui prendrait au moins un
an selon selon les meilleurs experts
donc à moins qui des éléments de
renseignement sur ce sujet ça veut dire
que même si l'Iran le décidait ce qui
n'est pas le cas en tout cas apparemment
aujourd'hui il lui faudrait quand même
même au avoir il faudrait quand même au
moins 1 an avant de disposer d'un engin
euh d'un engin prêt à la à la détonation
les les les les ruptures possibles bien
sûr le toujours toujours concevable
retrait iranien du TNP mais ce n'est pas
parce que nous pensons que ce n'est pas
dans l'intérêt de les Iraniens qui le
feront jamais beaucoup de gens pensaient
que ça n'était pas dans l'intérêt de la
Russie d'envir l'Ukraine bah pas de
chance les la manière dont nous
concevons les intérêts des autres n'est
pas forcément et même rarement la
manière dont eux conçoivent leurs
propres intérêts donc c'est toujours une
bonne une bonne gymnastique mentale
essayons de pas nous projeter dans la
tête des autres et ne prétendons pas
connaître leurs intérêts mieux qu'ils
les connaissent connaissent eux-mêmes
l'autre rupture possible c'est bien sûr
le bombardement israélien là encore je
crois que c'est extrêmement peu probable
je pense je l'ai toujours dit euh je
pense que le la la la le seuil dans les
faits le seuil de l'action même pour un
gouvernement ement tel que celui qui est
au pouvoir aujourd'hui à Jérusalem reste
un seuil reste un seuil extrêmement haut
enfin dernière dernière tendance une
bataille de l'influence en Afrique de
plus en plus difficile pour la France et
si je vous si je je cherchais une
rupture je la vois pas vraiment mais je
dirais que l'effet de contagion ne
pourrait ne pas s'arrêter là et qu'après
tout des manipulations habiles de la
part de la Russie ajouté à des
maladresses toujours possible de la part
de la France pourrait faire en sorte que
le mouvement de contagion voire
d'imitation se poursuivent et et ça
malheureusement c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne peut qu'on ne peut qu'on ne
peut pas du tout exclure à partir de là
quatre quatre réflexion très brèves sur
les choix pour notre pays d'abord sur la
dépense de défense euh ce n'est pas
parce que les autres dépenses qu'on doit
faire de même euh il n'y a pas de
relation mécanique entre les la la la
dépense militaire des Chinois des Russes
des iranien et d'autres et et cell de la
France en revanche je crois que la vraie
question pour nous sur l'avenir de notre
budget de la défense c'est notre la
relation avec nos alliés autrement dit
on ne peut pas peser au sein de l'Europe
de la défense et au sein de l'OTAN sans
être un acteur qui montre qu'il prend en
compte l'ensemble des phénomènes dont
j'ai dont j'ai parlé il y a quelques
instants et qui entend demeurer sur le
long terme un acteur militaire de
premier plan donc je dirais que pour
pour moi la question au dehors de de de
besoins que que vous connaissez je dira
que la la l'aspect politique de la
dépense de défense il est sur il est
beaucoup plus important vis-à-vis de nos
de nos de nos alliés de nos amis plutôt
que de nos adversaires deuxième élément
de réflexion il y a une petite musique
parfois dans les ccles de réflexion qui
consiste à dire il faut se retirer
d'Afrique pour pouvoir se réinvestir
dans l'OT temp alors c'est un choix
facile qui ne correspond jamais parce
que c'est un choix trop facile ça
correspond pas au choix politiqu les
choix politiques c'est toujours beaucoup
plus complexe que cela et vous le savez
beaucoup mieux que moi euh
on peut comprendre l'idée parce qu'elle
est simple et ça fait un slogan de
t-shirt comme on disait aux États-Unis
mais d'abord d'une part je pense pas que
nous devions nous retirer totalement
d'Afrique ou en tout cas si on le
faisait on sera rappelé un jour en tout
cas l'histoire montre qu'il serait
imprudent de parier sur le fait que nous
ne serons pas rappelés en Afrique dans
les 10 ans qui viennent je dire ça comme
ça je pas parler du Moyen-Orient mais
évidemment le Moyen-Orient a toujours
aussi la la la mauvaise idée de se
rappeler au bons souvenir des cidents au
moment où on s'y au moment où s'y attend
où on s'y attend le moins en revanche il
n'est pas illégitime de de continuer à
réfléchir sur la place que nous voulons
avoir dans le dispositif de première
ligne de l'OTAN est-ce que nous sommes
satisfaits de voir les Polonais et les
Allemands prendre prendre le liad ou
voulons-nous être un pays de première
ligne face dans un système de défense
collective qui devra s'installer dans la
durée pour dissuader d'abord et parer
éventuellement à une éventuelle
provocation russe à à nos frontières 4è
pardon 3è élément n'oublions pas la
Turquie qui semble s'être un petit peu
assagie dans son comportement mais qui
bien sûr est à regarder tout
particulièrement pour nous dans la
mesure où nous avons un accord de
défense vous le savez bien avec la Grèce
qui est particulièrement contraignant et
où aussi et Thomas a bien fait de le
rappeler et aussi l'attitude de la
Turquie en cas de on va dire si si
l'Azerbaïjan comme malheureusement il
pourra le faire sans hardi encore un
petit peu plus ça sera un véritable
sujet d'interrogation dernier point je
peux pasempêcher de de dire que même si
nous parlons beaucoup des menaces
visibles les menaces invisibles sont
peut-être aujourd'hui celles qui sont
les plus préoccupante pour notre
sécurité de français et d'Européen et
pour notre autonomie stratégique de
français et d'Européens je pense au
pillage de notre savoir-faire
scientifique et technologique et pas
seulement de la part de nos adversaires
je pense bien sûr aussi à la
désinformation et la manipulation
politique la manière dont la Russie la
Chine et d'autres agissent en dépit de
de notre de nos réactions souvent très
saines sur ce sujet je crois que la
France se laisse de moins en moins faire
mais les moyens qui ont été mis par ces
pays au au service de la de la
désinformation et et de la manipulation
politique en Europe j'espère d'ailleurs
qu'on en verra pas trop à l'occasion du
scrutin européen de l'an prochain c'est
quelque chose sur lequel il faut avoir
une vigilance extrême parce que c'est
moins visible ça ça fait moins
fonctionner les industries mais c'est à
mon sens au moins aussi important pour
l'avenir de notre pays et de de notre
République merci à tous les trois pour
vos interventions je pense qu'il nous
rassure sur un seul point c'est qu'on
aura beaucoup de travail dans les années
qui qui
arrivve j'ai se orateurs de de groupe et
cinq questions complémentaires alors
m'adressant au aux orateurs de groupe je
pense qu'on a deux options pour pour
l'organisation de cette audition c'est
soit vous souhaitez une réponse
immédiate d'uninvenant que vous
choisissez ou soit vous souhaitez une
réponse mutualisée des différents
orateurs de groupe voilà qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous préférez on peut peut
faire un mix des deux est-ce que vous
préférez poser une question à une
personne et avoir une réponse
immédiatement ou est-ce que je prends
l'ensemble des orateurs de groupe et on
aura une réponse
mutualisée très bien bon donc donc je
prends l'ensemble des orateurs de groupe
très bien donc pour le groupe
Renaissance la parole est à Anne pour
une durée de 2 minutes merci beaucoup
c'est tellement vos propos sont
tellement denses que c'est pas facile
d'en extraire le point sur lequel je
voudrais insister je note que votre
carte blanche à part monsieur tertray
qui a fait un petit peu allusion ne
parle que très très peu de la situation
en Indo-Pacifique dont je reviens encore
mais bon vous aurez peut-être l'occasion
de développer c'est pas là-dessus je
voudrais accer ma question je vis
revenir sur le fait que historiquement
bah nous en Occident on avait envisagé
la paix sous l'angle du droit ensuite on
envisagé sous l'angle de l'économie et
des échanges et puis maintenant on est
bien obligé de se rendre à l'évidence on
est obligé de l'envisager sous l'angle
de la force on y est vraiment contraint
avec une Russie qui a clairement pour
ambition de voir la paix dans son dans
sa région contre des territoires et tout
ça avec en filigrin derrière la
déstabilisation de notre Occident
démocratique avec un comportement vous
l'avez évoqué monsieur tertray on voit
bien qu'il nous mène à nous
indirectement des guerres multiples et
il y en a pas qu'une seule il mène une
cybergerre il mne une guerre de
l'information il mène une guerre de
l'énergie il mène une guerre de
l'alimentation vous l'avez évoqué même
même même une guerre de d'migration euh
de l'autre côté du côté de l'Ukraine
enfin pour nous en tout cas notre
urgence c'est évidence le président de
la République l'a rappelé une Ukraine
victorieuse un Vladimir Poutine je dis
bien Vladimir Poutine des fait je parle
pas de la Russie je parle de Poutine et
je pense que j'aimerais avoir votre
votre réaction là-dessus faut-il
vraiment avoir peur d'une Russie sans
Poutine des études des analyes disent en
tout cas Américains disent que c'est pas
forcément nécessaire il faut également
mieux nous protéger collectivement nous
avons pour cela l'Union européenne d'un
côté et l'OTAN de l'autre et là c'était
une de mes questions sur l'Union
européenne pensez-vous que les traités
qui constituent notre Union européenne
qui n'avaient pas anticipé une situation
de crise dans laquelle nous sommes
peuvent suffire à répondre à à la crise
à la recherche de paix à laquelle nous
ambitionnons et puis sur la Russie cont
tenu des différentes guerres qui nous
qui nous mène et puis de leur
comportement sur le terrain en Ukraine
qui est un comportement qu'on peut
assimiler du fait des crimes de guerre
un comportement terroriste peut-on
considérer que soit Poutine soit ses
armées soit son gouvernement je ne crois
pas à l'état tout entier mais j'auris
voà avoir votre retour peut-être
considéré analysé perçu comme un état
terroriste et quels sont les conditions
les les conséquences que ça pourrait
avoir sur l'attitude que nous devrions
avoir merci beaucoup pour le groupe
rassemblement national la parole est à
Caroline
Colombier merci monsieur le Président
merci messieurs pour vos interventions
de très grande qualité dans un monde
complexe et en en profonde mutation
comme vous l'avez dit il est toujours
agréable de disposer d'experts sur les
questions internationales et je me
réjouis à cette à cette égar avec
l'ensemble des collègues de mon grour
rassemblement national de la recherche
de très grande qualité mené par vos
instituts vos travaux éclairent un monde
d'un regard précieux et ils offrent une
vision complémentaire et indispensable à
la recherche anglo-saxonne très
prolifique mais va toujours tendre avec
la France c'est précisément sur ces
engés de perception que je vais centrer
mon propos avec un pays un pays que
l'Europe et singulièrement la France ne
serurait inuré qui est la Turquie ce
pays est censé être un allié notamment
dans le cadre de l'OTAN et il représente
la deuxème armée en TER d'effectif ce
pays devrait même être un ami au regard
de la longue histoire de nos relations
diplomatiques lancé sous l'Empire
ottoman sous le règ de François I et de
Soliman i les relations franco-turques
se sont poursuivies avec la République
de Turquie fondée par
ataturque la Turquie des kémalistes est
d'ailleurs directement inspiré par le
modèle républicain français et c'est un
des rares pays laïques au monde avec la
France ou du moins je dirais c'était car
il faut dire que la nouvelle Turquie
vantée par le président Erdogan et ses
turiférir et bien différente sur le plan
intérieur du modèle égalitaire et laïque
français les femmes turques en sont un
exemple puisqu'elles avaient obtenu le
droit de vote en 1934 soitisans avant la
France et qu'elles sont maintenant
invitées à rester chez elles et à faire
au moins trois enfants selon le slogan
tristement célèbre d'Erdogan la Turquie
a basculé dans un enfer digne de Kafka
avec des opposants ou de simples
critiques de dérives de pouvoir
implaacablement traqués emprisonnés des
dizaines de milliers de fonctionnaires
ont été purgés vos homologues chercheurs
Turcs sont également des cibles
privilégié du gouvernement islamiste je
dis bien islamiste et non pas démocrate
musulm ou encore islamo conservateur
pour reprendre des étiquettes données
précisément par des chercheurs lors de
l'arrivée au pouvoir
d'Erdogan le constat est tout aussi
cruel quant aux relations extérieures de
la Turquie un influent ministre puis
Premier ministre de d'Erdogan Ahmet
davotoulou avait pour slogan une
politique de zéro problème avec les
voisins l'ennui c'est qu'il faudrait
plutôt dire aujourd'hui zéro voisin sans
problème Ankara ne se prive pas
d'incursion militaire régulière en Irak
ou en Syrie pour combattre les rebelles
kurgs du PKK ou de similair le soutien à
à l'Azerbaïdjan pardon dans sa guerre au
haut cararabakh contre l'Arménie est
clairement affirmé le régime a même
réussi à se concilier des officiers de
marine pourtant réputé fidèle à
l'héritage d'ataturque en recyclant leur
projets de patrie bleue qui visent ni
plus moins à rétablir une une hégémonie
turque sur la Méditerranée et qui menace
directement la Grèce pays alliés et
membre de l'UE pire encore concernant la
France et j'ai fini vaut-il rappeler les
compromissions des autorités turques
avec notre ennemi daesh en Syrie
l'allumage de l'un de nos navires de
Marine nationale en Méditerranée sans
oublier le travail de SAP auquel se
livre encara dans ce contexte j'ai trois
questions et j'arrête Erdogan récemment
réélu président est-il susceptible de
changer son attitude vis-à-vis de l'OTAN
comme il l'a fait avec Vladimir Poutine
ou Bachar al-Assad quels sont les
leviers et les résultats concrets
d'ankcara dans sa politique d'expansion
de ses intérêts en Afrique et avons-nous
la certitude que même si l'opposition
turque revenait au pouvoir la Turquie
reviendrait à une position plus
prooccidentale sur la scène mondiale je
vous remercie et je m'excuse pour le le
petit débordement oui c'est même un gros
débordement mais voilà on va essayer de
rester dans dans le timing en tout cas
la question a été posée avec avec
conviction gros sujet pour le groupe la
France insoumise la parole est à
François pimal
oui monsieur le Président
euh messieurs les les directeurs je
voudrais vous remercier pour vos
interventions évidemment mais peut-être
revenir sur quelque chose qui a été peu
évoqué ou alors en filégâne c'est votre
analyse des conséquences des changements
climatiques et la perspective sur sur
les conflits qui peuvent en découler
monsieur tertray par exemple en 2011
vous avez publié un ouvrage qui
s'appelait l'Apocalypse n'est pas pour
demain dans lequel vous disiez douter un
petit peu de la nécessité d'investir
massivement dans la transition
écologique or à l'occasion du G20 et de
l'Assemblée général des nations- unies
le secrétaire général de l'ONU n'a cessé
d'alerter sur le danger que représentait
les changements climatiques pour
l'humanité quelle analyse en faites-vous
aujourd'hui euh les changements
climatiques on les a vu récemment le
tremblement de terre au Maroc les
inondations en Libye les feux de forêt
en France en Grèce ou en Tunisie sont
pour certains liés à
cela aussi euh nous avons proposé en
2008 euh nous avons proposé pardon la
création d'une organisation commune
méditerranéenne de sécurité civile
laquelle verrait les États du
bassin méditerranéen pardon je vais y
arriver mettre en commun leurs forces
pour faire face aux événements qui sont
croissants dans la région que
pensez-vous de cette idée de ressérer
les liens politiques et opérationnels
entre les États de la Méditerranée et je
laisse mes 30 secondes tout à l'heure à
mon à mon camarade qui posera la
question très bien merci beaucoup pour
le bon respect du du temps de parole
pour le groupe les républicains la
parole est à Jean-Louis
tiierot merci monsieur le Président
merci messieurs pour cette intervention
qui comme à chaque fois fait que nous
sortons un peu plus intelligent de cette
séance que quand nous y arrivons deux
petites questions précises et ensuite
une analyse globale qui s'adresse à à
chacun d'entre vous les deux petites
questions précises Pascal Boniface vous
avez dit que vous considériez que le
pacte de quinsy était dé facto mort
j'aurais souhaité avoir votre éclairage
à tous sur on va dire l'état euh de mort
réel cérébral ou encore sauvable du du
pacte de qu'insi deuxème question aussi
ponctuelle nous avons eu une un coup de
chaud dans les relations polono
ukrainienne comment l'analysez-vous
est-ce que c'est simplement euh les
effets d'une campagne électorale qui se
passe d'une manière compliqué euh pour
le la majorité en place en Pologne ou
est-ce que c'est quelque chose de plus
structurant lié à des rivalités
économiques au problèmes agricoles enfin
ce que nous connaissons votre regard euh
m'intéresse beaucoup question plus
général nos amis allemands ont parlé
après la crise en Ukraine de Side 22 de
changement d'époque ce qui arrive en
Afrique aujourd'hui pour la France et
aussi peut-être une forme de Side vend
français de de changement d'époque donc
quelle conclusion en tirer pour notre
outil de défense pour notre architecture
globale de ces sécurité avec une
question qui est liée si nous souhaitons
et je partage l'analyse générale que
vous avez porté si nous souhaitons que
la France la dernière des poupées gigogn
dans l'architecture européenne de
sécurité soit plus influente ça veut
dire plus de moyens et plus de capacités
sur le théâtre aéroterrestre donc que
faut-il viser comme format et question
corollaire après la guerre en Ukraine
dont nul ne sait comment elle finira
évidemment que ça dépend de la la
manière dont elle finira à quelle
rapidité la Russie serait-elle capable
d'avoir un outil militaire conventionnel
qui nous menace et là j'ai une légère
divergence avec Pascal Boniface quand il
dit il n'arrive pas à venir à bout de
l'Ukraine serait-il un jour capable de
s'engager contre un pays de l'OTAN la
vraie question c'est vu leur économie de
guerre à quel stade il pourrait devenir
menaçant et aurions-nous le temps de
nous adapter merci pour le groupe
démocrate la parole est à Delphine
lingeman merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les directeurs au nom du
groupe déémocrate je tiens tout d'abord
à à vous remercier pour vos propos
liminires fort éclairant ma question va
va porter sur l'Europe et notamment le
modèle géopolitique àéinventé pour
l'Union
européenne l'Europe après une phase de
construction et ou de structuration et
actuellement et depuis quelques années
dans une phase plutôt de turbulence je
vais citer quelques éléments NOTAM
notment le plus impactant c'est le
retour de la guerre à haute intensité en
Europe la crise du brexit la montée des
populisme la crise migratoire avec
aucune solution ou une solution qui est
extrêmement difficile à trouver à
l'échelle européenne et qui pourtant est
la bonne échelle les relations
franco-allemande et la germanophone et
germanophile que je
suis s'en attriste
fortement l'intégration aussi des pays
candidats à ce ou jours six pays
candidats et certaines candidatures
posent questionnement y compris celle de
l'Ukraine récemment il y a des petites
voies qui s'élève notamment sur la
puissance agricole de l'Ukraine qui
viendrait finalement jouer un
redistribuer les cartes au niveau de des
aides de la PAC notamment
voilà et puis tout le tout
l'environnement géopolitique
internationale qui est également source
d'instabilité je vais pas revenir
là-dessus alors à la lumière finalement
de de de
ça j'aimerais avoir votre avis quel est
quelles seraient les solutions pour
réinventer au regard ces constats le
modèle européen de demain et comment la
France peut jouer un rôle dans cette
dans cette dans ce nouveau modèle
européen à réinventer je vous remercie
merci pour le groupe socialiste la
parole est à Anna pic merci beaucoup et
merci pour ce tour d'horizon de la
situation il y a un sujet qu'on a pu
aborder c'est celui de l'Afrique même
s'il nous a pas mal préoccupé ces
dernières années ces derniers mois et
semaines dans l'actualité en effet le 26
juillet dernier Mohamed Bazou président
de la République du Niger été renversé
par un coup d'État orchestré par une
jeinte autoproclamée Conseil national
pour la sauvegarde de la patrie et à la
tête de ce conseil le général
Abdourahman tiani devient de facto chef
de l'État nigérien après le Mali en 2020
le Burkina Faso en 2022 le Niger qui est
restait l'ultime véritable allié de
Paris au Sahel et le 3ème pays a être
renversé en l'espace de 3 ans dans cette
région le constat est ainsi sans appel
la démocratie est en être recul et la
présence de la France fortement contesté
pour differses raisons la résurgence
d'une ranqueœur coloniale dans les états
où la France a trop longtemps continué à
user parfois d'un ton arrogant et d'une
attitude paternaliste l'impuissance
française à permettre le développement
économique et social de ces états une
profonde incompréhension quant à
lacacité de l'armée française perçue
comme l'une des meilleures du monde à
éliminer une menace dihadiste sous
équipe
et la méfiance vis-à-vis de l'idéal
démocratique importé d'Europe favorisé
on l'a dit par les influences étrangères
mais une démocratie souvent synonyme sur
le terrain de corruption d'élection
truqué et développement économique capté
par une élite dans ce contexte la CDAO
rapidement soutenu par Paris a menacé de
répondre militairement au PCH nigérien
alors même que certains pays membres de
cette organisation n'y sont pas vraiment
favorables l'intervention militaire dont
il est question pourrait d'ailleurs
s'avérer contre-productive en regroupant
ses forces à Niamé face à la menace la
jeinte militaire nigérienne pourrait
laisser le champ libre aux groupes armés
djihadistes pour s'emparer des
territoires du nord Niger à ce stade
seul des sanctions économiques ont été
prises par la CDAO lesquelles ont eu des
répercussions directes sur le prix des
denrées alimentaires en nigère et sur
les économies des pays membres de la
CDAO enfin celle-ci est perçue par
beaucoup comme le cheval de tro de la
France au détriment de sa légitimité
donc de son
efficacité ainsi
était-il plusieurs questions se posent
était-il opportun de soutenir aussi
promptement les intentions militaires de
la CDAO cela ne peut-il pas encore
fragiliser la présence de nos forces
dans la région qui pourrait
pourtant être à nouveau opérante
l'existence de de la CDAO n'est-elle pas
désormais menacée par le grand nombre de
pches en Afrique de l'Ouest les tensions
internes qui la traverse et l'émergence
récente de l'alliance des états du Sahel
issue de la charge de l'ptako Gourma les
pays de la CDAO accepteront-ils de
maintenir encore longtemps les sanctions
économiques contre le Niger alors que
celles-ci ont des répercussions sur les
économies
bref l'équilibre qui s'était établi
est-il à nouveau
menacé merci et je vois que pour la
rentré nous devons reprendre les bonnes
habitudes du respect du temps mais nous
commençons en douceur et enfin pour le
groupe horizon la parole est à loï
carvan merci merci monsieur le Président
tout d'abord les les députés du groupe
horizon vous remercie messieurs les
acteur pour la richesse et et
l'intelligence de de vos propos et à
titre personnel je trouve frappante
cette idée que vous évoquiez monsieur
Gomar que finalement les opinions
publiques occidentales ont le spectacle
de la guerre mais continuent à ne pas y
croire alors qu'en fait si nous prêtions
attention et que nous comptions les les
secondes entre l'éclair et le tonner
nous verrions que que l'orage se
rapproche et on peut pas s'empêcher de
de frissonner à cette à cette
perspective ma question va va porter sur
le Sahel un peu dans le prolongement
même si c'est
avec une optique légèrement différente
de ma collègue socialiste
euh j'aurais voulu avoir votre opinion
sur euh ce que moi je considère être une
poudrière qui est en train de de se
constituer sur les risques que cela
emporte pour le le continent africain et
pour l'Europe parce que finalement on a
une reprise du conflit entre Bamako et
et laazwad on a aussi une très forte
augmentation des attaques et de la
létalité des attaques terroristes on a
la perspective éventuellement de la
création d'un
corridor avec le lac Tchad qui viendrait
assez considérablement renforcer l'État
islamique dans la province du du Sahel
et donc là on a beaucoup d'ingrédients
pour faire une bulle au sud de l'Europe
extrêmement instable qui viendrait
perturber à la fois le continent
africain et peut-être l'Europe
j'aimerais avoir votre opinion là-dessus
et on peut se demander si finalement
nous ne sommes pas dans une situation
pire euh que celle dans laquelle nous
étions en 2013 je vous remercie merci
chers collègues alors messieurs les
directeurs nous avons une trentaine de
minutes pour répondre à ces questions
pour garder une vingtaine de minutes
pour les cinq questions dernières et
donc je vous propose de d'avoir un temps
de parole chacun de 10 minutes Monsieur
beniface Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE très bien V
pardon merci pour toutes vos questions
et ces toutes ces ces réflexions par
rapport à la première question est-ce
que les traités de l'Union européenne
sont suffisants pour répondre au niveau
défis on a deux défis par rapport à
l'Union européenne c'est les
perspectives d'un élargissement qui
pourrait nous mener à 34 35 états c'est
déjà difficile à gérer à 27 avec une
perspective de nous le cachons pas d'un
vote à la majorité qui est populaire
dans les opinions publiques mais qui
serait une défaite pour la France
puisque ça serait donné les clés de la
construction européenne à l'Allemagne et
donc il faut se méfier de ces
propositions euh et en fait et du coup
je réponds à une autre question aussi
qui a été posé plus tard quel avenir
pour l'Union européenne le seul avenir
c'est vraiment une Europe à géométrie
qui variable à CERC concentrique à
plusieurs cercles parce que nous avons
plusieurs noyaux nous n'avons pas la
même histoire nous n'avons pas les mêmes
intérêts nous avons des structures
différentes pas les même état économi
pas les mêmes pertion stratégiques donc
pensez que l'on va agir communément à 34
alors qu'on a déjà du mal même si on y
parvient parfois à se mettre d'accord à
27 est une illusion et je pense qu'il
faut travailler de nouveau à ces cercles
concentriques à ces noyaux différents
dans lequel on peut plus facilement
faire des choses une Russie sans Poutine
Poutine a échoué je pense qu'il a perdu
cette guerre même s'il garde une enclave
territoriale en Ukraine la Russie
sortira moins puissante moins forte
qu'elle n'est rentrée dans cette guerre
et quelque part lui qui et avec succès
avec brutalité et répression pendant 20
ans a grandi le statut de la Russie sur
la scène mondiale a redonné une fierté
aux Russes d'être russe a perdu là en
grande partie dilapider ces 20 ans de
travail constant avec ces méthodes qui
sont les enne mais il est certain que la
question qu'il posait régulièrement où
on était la Russie quand j'ai pris le
pouvoir on était le maintenant on
pouvait répondre elle en situation ce
n'est plus le cas mais pour autant on
peut très bien se maintenir au pouvoir
dans un pays qui va de plus en plus mal
dans un pays où il y a un million 1
million et demi de Russes qui sont
partis ceux qui sont partis c'était la
fine fleur c'était les gens éduqués les
gens qui pouvaient moderniser le pays
les gens qui travaillaient sur les
nouvelles technologies sur
l'intelligence artificielle tous ces
gens-là vont manquer durablement et je
pense que cette fuite des cerveaux pèse
encore plus sur la minè de la Russie que
les sanctions qui ont été prises qui
pèsent également mais peut-être moins
que cela mais on peut rester regardez
Bachar el-Assad il a ruiné son pays il
est toujours au pouvoir et Poutine par
la répression peut se maintenir au
pouvoir même dans un pays affaibli
est-ce que la Russie est un état
terroriste alors est-ce que lorsqu'on
bombarde des populations civiles on est
terroriste mais dans ce cas-là de
nombreux pays ont bombardé des
populations civiles je pense que les
crimes de guerre sont sont documentés la
Russie a commis des crimes de guerre qui
sont largement documentés en Ukraine oui
on peut dire que la Russie veut
terroriser la population ukrainienne
faute de pouvoir conquérir l'état
ukrainien mais la qualifation la
qualification d'État terroriste je pense
que le fait qu'il y ait des crimes de
guerre voire des crimes contre
l'humanité est un qualificatif suffisant
suffisamment pénalisant au niveau
international pour la Russie qui
d'ailleurs empêche Poutine d'aller dans
certains pays que de se battre sur une
qualification d'État terroristes sur la
Turquie on peut se poser la question
parce que vous avez madame rappelé la
bonnes relations les bonnes relations
que nous avions avec la Turquie
historiquement et même dans une période
récente qui a perdu la Turquie est-ce
que la Turquie s'est perdu ou est-ce que
c'est nous qui l'avons perdu en lui
claquant trop brutalement la porte au
neée de façon peut-être un peu cavalière
mais il est certain que les perspective
d'adhésion de la Turquie à l'Union
européenne dont j'étais partisan il y a
15 ans ne me paraisse plus possible
aujourd'hui ourd'hi du fait de
l'attitude de Monsieur Erdogan des
restrictions au Liberté moi j' mes amis
et collègues turqu me disait il y a 10
15 ans on n' pas voté Erdogan forceé de
constater qu'il a fait de la Turquie un
pays plus respecté dans le monde
maintenant ils ont fu la Turquie ils
sont réfugiés en France où ils craignent
et donc ça a changé et donc
effectivement on a un problème Erdogan
joue sur tous les tableaux il est devenu
incontournable il c'est l'un des
bénéficiaires de la guerre en Ukraine
parce que le relative de la Turquie a
augmenté et et donc ben il joue sa carte
en étant à la fois du côté des Russes
quand ça l'arrange du côté des
États-Unis quand ça l'arrange de l'autre
côté quand ça l'arrange et il joue sur
l'ensemble des tableaux il a renforcé sa
donne mais la situation du pays n'est
pas très bonne c'est moin que l'on
puisse dire et est-ce que l'opposition
si elle était venue au pouvoir de peu et
ça a échoué dans des conditions quand
même un peu contestable de débat
démocratique mais si l'opposition venait
au pouvoir elle serait moins moins
confrontative avec nous mais elle
défendrait les intérêts national de la
Turquie et il y aurait des points de
désaccord encore avec nous sur le
changement climatique c'est
effectivement l'une des menaces les plus
à la sécurité les plus fortes et c'est
vrai que la guerre en Ukraine nous
détourne un peu de ce combat notamment
parce que les sommes qui sont consacrées
à défendre l'Ukraine et à nous défendre
contre cet environnement ne sont pas
consacrés à la lutte contre champ
climatique et dans le propos j'avais
parlé de la division versus de rest les
pays du reste nous reprochent beaucoup
en disant tout l'argent que vous enveyez
en Ukraine dont une partie est
considérée comme de l'aide publique au
développement ne va pas à nous et vous
nous demandez à faire une transition
énergétique alors que on na pas les
moyens de le faire et que vous détournez
d' style ou attribuer à d'autres ces
moyens et que donc c'est à la fois un
enjeu toujours majeur mais qui est de
long terme l'urgence est ailleurs et bah
c'est vrai que la décarbonation de
l'économie internationale n'est pas
encore suffisamment en route sur le pack
de Quincy ce que j'ai voulu dire
monsieur le député c'est qu'il a c'est
pas une coupure entre l'Arabie saite et
les États-Unis il y a pas une rupture
les Saoudiens veulent toujours avoir des
relations avec les États-Unis mais voilà
ils ont d'autres options c'était une
sorte je dirais de mariage catholique si
j'ose dire avec les États-Unis
auparavant là ils peuvent avoir des
options tout à fait différente sur
Pologne et Ukraine moi je suis depuis
longtemps je dis qu'il faut se méfier de
la musique qu'on entend très F en disant
que la Pologne a été la plus
clairvoyante sur la Russie qu'ils ont eu
raison ce gouvernement est quand même
problématique et il le prouve et les
changements de enfin si un président
français ou un chancelier allemand avait
eu sur monsieur Zelenski les propos que
monsieur doudaa a eu que n'aurait-on dit
et donc on voit que bah le gouvernement
polonais n'a peut-être moins une
politique à long terme que l'on ne
pensait mais que ils sont capables
finalement de naviguer à vue en fonction
de circonstances électorale
effectivement en Afrique c'est un
changement d'époque vous avez
parfaitement raison et là je on ne peut
pas faire autre chose que de tout
rebattir puisque une grande partie a
échoué le renouveau militaire de la
Russie euh oui bien sûr ils vont pouvoir
reconstruire mais ils ont pris une
grosse claque et je pense quand même
même si il faut rester prudent que ils
auront du mal de serit de leur
affaiblissement économique du fait de la
guerre et des sanctions et de la perte
des compétenence il y a quand même
beaucoup d'ingénieurs qui sont partis et
et donc ils auront quand même du mal à
reconstruire mais je veux dire tant
qu'il y aura pas un régime réellement
démocratique en Russie il faudra garder
un œil attentif euh sur Ukraine UE moi
je pense très honnêtement madame que ça
serait une catastrophe si l'Ukraine
rentrait dans l'Union européenne et
qu'on a une réponse émotionnelle un
problème géopolitique que que l'on
défend l'Ukraine agressé très bien mais
notre agriculture qui est quand même une
force essentielle de notre pays pour
notre souveraineté pour notre
rayonnement pour notre alimentation tout
ce que là l' agriculture ne survivrait
pas à l'entrée de l'Ukraine dans l'Union
européenne et on a confondu la
solidarité stratégique qu'on doit avoir
avec un pays agressé par un autre avec
le fait de lui ouvrir les clés et ce que
je crains c'est que on dit bien sûr
attention c'est très long il y aura des
gardes de fous il y a quand même un
petit problème de corruption dans ce
pays et je crains que on soit pris dans
une NAS et que maintenant qu'on a lancé
le mouvement il n'est pas certain que
l'on puisse puisse appuyer sur le bouton
STOP à plusieurs moments et je suis
extrêmement inquiet et sur vre question
du modèle européen j'ai répondu sur les
les cercles concentriques était-il
judicieux de soutenir la CDAO on pouvait
avoir une menace militaire mais
évidemment je veux dire toutes les
interventions militaires depuis début ce
siècle sont des échecs donc il faut
réfléchir à cela c'est c'est partout des
échecs y compris celle la seule qui a
été un succès celle au Mali en 2013 qui
sait en étant en changeant de signe en
étant trop longue ver un échec euh mais
donc est-ce que la CDO est menacée oui
elle l'est mais pas tout à fait et à
votre question madame faut-il maintenir
les sanctions contre le Niger moi je
suis pas d' des sanctions je trouve que
très souvent elle sanctionne ceux qui
les prennent que très souvent sanctionne
la population et pas les gouvernements
mais je ferai exception dans le cas du
Niger parce que il ne faut bien sûr pas
faire d'intervention militaire parce que
même si on renverser le nouveau régime
qu'est-ce qu'on ferait après et ce n'est
même pas sûr que l'intervention
réussirait mais ensuite comme contrôler
le Niger avec des soldats étrangers ça
ne marcherait jamais par contre les
sanctions elles peuvent fonctionner du
fait du caractère enclavé du Niger de
l'imimportance du Nigéria par rapport à
l'économie et c'est peut-être la seule
réponse que l'on peut avoir par rapport
à ce coup d'État est-ce qu'il y a un
recul démocratique pas tout à fait
puisque en fait ce n'était pas des
réelles démocraties très honnêtement
encore plus au Gabon qui était une
cleptocratie voilà
sur la la question de Monsieur carvrand
oui effectivement la situation n'est
toujours pas contrôlée mais et je pense
que annoncer comme on l'a fait qui on
allit faire la guerre contre le
terrorisme au s était une erreur parce
que cette notion n'a pas réussi au
Moyen-Orient elle peut pas réussir en
Afrique de l'Ouest et effectivement les
gens disaient la la France qui est d'
armée puissante et ça répond madame pic
à votre intervention les gens disaient
bah la France qui une armé puissante dit
qu'elle fait guerre contre Rist elle ne
le gagne pas donc il y a un loup bah non
il y a pas de loup parce que on peut pas
contrôler un territoire avec 5000 hommes
aussi grand que l'Union européenne merci
la parole est à Thomas gomard
merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames messieurs les députés pour vos
questions je vais les reprendre aussi
dans l'ordre en commençant par celle de
Madame
Jun sur l'Indopacifique effectivement on
a pas parlé on a peut-être pas parlé
parce qu'en réalité tout le monde
comprend les choses intellectuellement
stratégiquement mais parler de
l'Indo-Pacifique au moment où les choses
se délitent à cette vitesse et en Europe
et en Afrique pourrait sembler un peu
paradoxal même s'il y a des effets de
bord entre éidment ce qui se passe dans
le détroit de Taiwan ce qui se passe à
hormous ou ce qui se passe dans dans le
bosfor moi je note la
nécessité de d'essayer d'être plus
cohérent dans not démarche vis-àis de
l'Indo-Pacifique et surprenant par
exemple de découvrir que un pays comme
la France n'a pas d'attacher de défense
aux Philippines alors même
que voilà donc y a y a il y a un
décalage si vous voulez très fort entre
euh conception intellectuelle qu'on
partage et la réalité des moyens que ce
soit les moyens navals ou que ce soit
les moyens diplomatique et que ce qui
nous est souvent dit dans les échanges
que nous pouvons avoir avec nos
collègues dans l'univers des Fing tank
c'est c'est très bien votre stratégie
Indo-Pacifique enfin essayez déjà de
gérer votre propre voisinage bon euh et
c'est un argument à mon avis euh qu'il
faut qu'il faut entendre après
développer les liens avec le Japon
développer les liens avec avec des pays
comme le le Vietnam Singapour et cetera
évidemment euh considérer que ce qui se
passe dans le détroit de Taiwan concerne
la la sécurité européenne par effet de
bord évidemment mais je pense qu'il faut
sur cette notion d'indo-pacifique
prendre garde à euh garder toujours à
l'esprit la dialectique entre objectif
et
moyens alors sur la Russie
euh Russie avec Poutine sans Poutine
écoutez j'ai moi l'habitude de répondre
à cette question de la manière suivante
c'est que on a vu en juin ce que aurait
pu être une alternative politique à
Vladimir Poutine elle s'appelait evgie
prigouine et ça ça illustre au fond le
degré de régression aujourd'hui du
système russe dans sa composante
politique militaire sécuritaire et
mafieuse et donc le sujet c'est de se
poser la question qu'aurait été notre
attitude si EVG Prigogine était allé au
bout de sa chevauchée de soudard en
fait autrement dit je pense qu'on a à
faire un des indépendamment de la
question même de l'évolution de la
situation en Ukraine on a affaire à un
régime qui est aujourd'hui complètement
vicié qui ne qui ne résume évidemment
pas les débats qui peuvent exister en
Russie parce qu'il y a plein de Russes
qui sont tout à fait conscients et de de
cette situation et qui qui aimerait en
sortir je crois qu'il faut il faut
effectivement bien intégrer le fait que
le dialogue avec avec la Russie dans la
génération à venir va être extrêmement
difficile bon sur les qualification
d'État terroristes moi j'aiage ass de
d'essayer peut-être d'encourager une
forme de prudence dans le vocabulaire
parce que c'est toujours facile de
maximiser des objectifs et des enjeux
quand précisément on reste à distance et
au spectacle en
fait je crois que déjà si nous
contentions d'être sérieux dans notre
soutien à l'Ukraine sans forcément aller
vers des
déclarations très très vives de désigner
sous tel ou tel qualificatif la Russie
ça serait déjà pas mal et je pense qu'il
faut prendre garde là aussi au décalage
entre les mots et les
choses sur les sanctions et bien au fond
euh ce que nous avons produit c'est que
les trois pays les plus sanctionnés au
monde la Russie la Corée du Nord l'Iran
vont les contourner
ensemble et que par ailleurs ce sont nos
trois principaux problèmes
stratégiques la question madame sur la
Turquie avant avant avant d'y
répondre peut-être j'étis intéressé de
votre introduction quand vous avez
mentionné la la la production
anglo-saxone dans laquelle nous
bignerions je pense que la force de nos
instituts de recherche c'est précisément
aussi d'être très attentif à la
production en langue russe dans le cas
de de contribu à titre personnel pendant
des années d'être d'essayer de suivre la
production en chinois quand c'est
possible autrement dit il faut bien
comprendre ce que ce qu'est l'industrie
des f tank au niveau mondial et que
cette industrie est en train d'être
bouleversée parce que vous avez des
investissements tout à fait
spectaculaires en terme de moyens à
louer je pense évidemment un régime
comme la Chine je pense évidemment un
régime comme comme la Russie je pense
évidemment au pays du golf qui font
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes nous Fing
tank européen et particulièrement
français dans une asymétrie de moyens
assez
redoutable euh sur le sur votre question
plus plus précise sur Erdogan je serai
peut-être moins sévère que vous sur ce
qui a été obtenu par euh euh le
président Erdogan dans la mesure où si
on regarde les choses de manière froide
euh il avait pour seul contact après
2016 euh au fond le Qatar et la Russie
bon et ce qu'il a réussi à rétablir
c'est une situation intermédiaire où il
vend des armes il soutient l'Ukraine
avec des drones au début du au début du
conflit et en même temps il accueille
euh beaucoup coup de Russes qui sortent
de qui sortent du du pays ù négocient
l'accord séré allié de l'été 2022
vis-à-vis de l'OTAN je pense qu'il fait
comprendre aux Européens le poids qui
est le sien en ralentissant le processus
d'adhésion de la Suède je crois que la
manière dont la la la Turquie s'ingère
parfois dans les campagnes électorales
en Europe est aussi un indicateur
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes face
effectivement à un régime qui a des
aspiration néo-impérial on pourrait les
les qualifier ainsi et en même temps qui
est membre de de l'OTAN comme comme vous
le savez donc il faut aussi je pense
prendre soin de pas être trop
catégorique dans nos jugements sur la
Turquie il y a là aussi une société
civile des débats politique au sein de
la Turquie qui n'ont rien à voir avec ce
qu'on peut observer en Russie hein
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup plus de d'espace même si c'est
un espace contraint qui s'est resserré
sous les années Erdogan une situation
économique absolument
désastreuse actuellement un rôle clé de
la Turquie dans son accueil au réfugiés
de syriie qui
continue à à s'observer et donc je pense
qu'il faut veiller à essayer de
maintenir la meilleure relation possible
avec la Turquie en ayant tout à fait à
l'esprit effectivement le dessin qui est
le sien la question de
Monsieur piicmal sur le changement
climatique alors vous avez mentionné le
livre de Bruno Tertry en 2011 que je
n'ai pas lu je je je le je le mais je
vais m'empresser de le faire après avoir
lu celui publié en 2023 évidemment non
plus sérieusement moi j'ai l'habitude de
dire si vous voulez que nous sommes face
à une une convergence entre deux
tendances très profonde la première
c'est l'accélération la dégradation
environnementale dans ces trois
composantes le réchauffement climatique
la perte de la biodiversité et les
pollutions et l'accélération la
propagation technologique pour le dire
autrement de la mise en données du monde
bon et donc moi je je considère que ces
questions climatiques deviennent un
enjeu géopolitique évident pour les
raisons que vous avez indiqué mais même
au-delà c'est-à-dire que le thème de
l'injustice de la justice ou de
l'injustice climatique effectivement
structure toute la relation Nord-Sud
puisque'au fond ces pays nous disent
deux choses la première c'est cette
situation a été créée par les conditions
de votre développement économique
pendant de siècles prier élément et
deuxème élément pourquoi vouloir nous
interdire au fond notamment de recourir
à des énergies fossiles pour assurer
notre propre développement économique et
donc là je pense que nous avons une
position extrêmement difficile à
défendre et qu'il faut être de mon point
de vue beaucoup plus allent dans les
deux grand succès de la diplomatie
française de mon point de vue au cours
de la dernière génération il y a eu
l'opposition de 2003 qui n'a pas eu de
finalité opérationnelle et puis il y a
eu les accords de Paris 2015 et je pense
que ça doit être une manière pour notre
diplomatie a de rester extrêmement
active et de pousser euh l'agenda global
dans toute dans toutes ces composantes
il y a quand même eu une amélioration
notamment de de l'aide au développement
qui a été voté je crois s Faur de ma
part à l'unanimité par par le Parlement
je pense que c'est probablement très
partagé mais là aussi il y a prob un
effort d'explication et surtout
d'accélération à opérer par rapport à
des pays qui se considère au fond qu'il
y aura des gagnants et des perdants euh
à ce réchauffement climatique juste une
parenthèse la Russie se considère comme
possible gagnante du réchauffement
climatique avec l'augmentation de de sa
surface cultivable c'est quelque chose
qui est tout à fait construit dans
l'entourage de de Vladimir Poutine je
pense qu'il faut être extrêmement
attentif sur un autre point géopolitique
des des enjeux de de réchauffement
climatique à aux enjeux de géoingénierie
c'est-à-dire que vous avez un un
investissement tout à fait massif avec
l'illusion de croire queon pourra
trouver des solutions locales ou
régionales illusion partagé aussi bien
aux États-Unis qu'en Chine évidemment
beaucoup moins en Europe mais les
investissements qu'on observe en terme
de géo inénierie là aussi c'est un
problème à mon avis pour les Européens
assez comparable à ce qu'on a pu
observer dans dans le numérique
c'est-à-dire qu'on veut réguler avant
d'avoir au fond inventter des choses et
on se fe se retrouver de ce point de
vue-là à mon avis avec des situations
difficiles un point ça me permet de de
répondre oui sur l'Arabie Saoudite en
fait l'Arabie Saoudite c'est tout à fait
intéressant pour ça par parce que
l'Arabie Saoudite est en train d'essayer
d'inventer un modèle qui lui est propre
qui est au fond de dire je m'enrichis
par le fossile pour essayer de financer
ma transition énergétique notamment en
investissant sur le nucléaire civil et
nous met dans une dépendance nous pour
financer notre propre transition
énergétique pour reprendre la la formule
du prés de la République où sont les
poches profondes elles sont aujourd'hui
dans les pays du golf avec aussi les
incidences que cela a en terme de de
système militaire je comprends que
j'étais trop long donc je m'arrête là et
je m'excuse auprès
des des députés auquels je n'ai pas pu
répondre il y aura une dernière phase de
réponse il y aura une voiture balai et
enfin la voiture la pardon la parole est
à Bruno TER je n'ai plus de voiture
monsieur le Président donc j'ai entamé
ma propre transition
énergétique sur la Russie sans Poutine
moi je me méfie un petit peu du discours
qui consiste à dire ça serait forcément
pire nous n'en savons rien il y a
plusieurs modèles de Russie sans Poutine
il y a il y a la Russie avec un autre
Poutine il y a la Russie
avec quelque chose de différent il y a
la Russie avec une nouvelle forme de de
une mutation de ce syndicat mafieux qui
la dirige aujourd'hui il y a la Russie
sans rien c'est-à-dire la Russie non
gouvernée dans les faits il y a
plusieurs modèles de de Russie sans
Poutine mais mfous toujours le discours
très populaire d'ailleurs chez les
autocrates qui consiste à dire vous ne
m'aimez pas mais sans moi ça serait
encore pire il reste le vrai scénario
auquel beaucoup de gens dans les sing
Tang pensent aujourd'hui sans le
souhaiter d'ailleurs
nécessairement c'est celui de
l'éclatement de la Russie ENF du
délitement du délitement de de
l'autorité du pouvoir central et là on
aurait de
nouveau la même discussion politique
comm 1991 c'est-à-dire est-ce que le
fait que la Russie est un état nucléaire
doit nous faire voir le problème d'une
manière particulière je je je ne je
ne on parle pas plus avant c'est c'est
c'est vraiment un sujet en soi sur la
catégorisation de la Russie comme état
terroriste je partage les préventions de
mes collègues c'est essentiellement une
catégorie américaine hein donc je sais
pas ce que ça apporte euh et puis il
faut savoir de quoi on parle est-ce
qu'on parle de du comportement de la
Russie qui qui se qui agirait comme un
terroriste ou de la Russie qui
soutiendrait des terroristes des acteurs
non étatiques qui vont faire les actions
violentes euh en Europe et ailleurs de
quoi parle-t-on la la notion d'état
terroriste est extrêmement ambigu donc
je partage j'ai des préventions de
principe je ne demande qu'à être
convaincu mais pour l'instant je ne je
ne le suis pas sur la Turquie de même
que Poutine n'est pas éternel Erdogan ne
l'est pas or les dirigeants ça compte et
je pense que ça compte peut-être
davantage en Turquie ou encore davantage
en Turquie qu'en Russie c'est-à-dire
queun Russie une Turquie sans Erdogan ça
serait très probablement quelque chose
de différent on ne reviendrait pas à
cette Turquie dont on rêve parfois en
France de manière un peu romantique ce
pays laïque qui nous aime François 1er
pas de voile à l'université et cetera
bon je suis pas sûr qu'on en revienne à
cette Turquie là mais en tout cas
Erdogan ou pas ça change je crois que
pour nous le le la difficulté consiste à
assumer notre relation de défense avec
la Grèce et le fait que la Turquie est
un allié de l'OTAN nous avons des
engagements de défense envers la Turquie
nous ne pouvons pas dédire sans aller
dans dans un jeu à somme nul eu tant que
bien sûr
Ankara ne commet pas l'irréparable
c'est-à-dire n'agresse pas le territoire
souverain d'un allié tel que la Grèce
euh ce que je trouve préoccupant
aujourd'hui c'est que on aurait pu
penser que dans sa grande magnanimité le
président Erdogan réélu euh demande la
ratification rapide par la grande
assemblé nationale de la l'adhésion de
la Suède je crois que Monsieur Erdogan
aime trop jouer euh euh jouer comme le
chat jouit avec la souris euh pardon
pour cette comparaison un peu légère
mais il adore ça c'est son truc et je
suis pas du tout certain que la question
soit réglée à échéance à échéance
prévisible monsieur PM je c je crois que
la la la question du changement
climatique d'abord vous avez bien fait
nous faire traiter de cette question
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a il y a des
choses dont on a pas traité don on
aurait dû dire un mot quand même je
crois que la question du changement
climatique est suffisamment préoccupante
pour ne pas en rajouter dans les risques
je je m'explique et je parle pas de vous
mais je parle de certaines littératur
d'un certain discours politique puisque
on parle de nos ouvrages respectifs j'en
ai fait un petit en 2016 qui s'appelle
guerre du climat contre enquête sur un
mythe moderne où j'ai littérature
scientifique à l'appuie essayer de
démonter cette cette facilité causale
qui consiste à dire le changement
climatique va mécaniquement augmenter ou
la fréquence ou l'intensité des conflits
je pense que la du point de vue logique
argumentatif et scientifique il y a
extrêmement peu d'arguments pour pour
soutenir pour soutenir cette thèse de
même d'ailleurs de même d'ailleurs que
autrement dit la chète de causalité est
tellement longue que dire que le
changement climatique conduit
mécaniquement à un accroissement soit de
l'intensité soit du nombre des conflits
me paraître extrêmement fragile de même
d'ailleurs sur une question très voisine
la question des migrants climatiques sur
laquelle on pourrait faire peut-être une
audition entière me paraître extrêmement
fragile je vous invite à lire ce que dit
le GC sur le sujet parce que tout le
monde sa m citer à raison le GC mais
alors regardez ce que dit qui en gros
démonte la catégorie migration
climatique et vous dit d'accord déplacer
environnementaux mais l'idée de dire
qu'il y aura des masses de gens qui vont
sortir de leur pays principalement à
cause des conséquences du changement
climatique c'est une notion extrêmement
extrêmement fragile donc pardon d'ouvrir
de nouvelles pistes de réflexion ici et
je crois qu'encore une fois ça
mériterait des auditions entières mais
euh l'idée de dire le changement
climatique est mécaniquement un problème
qui va accro qui va rendre encore plus
complexe et difficile la gestion de la
sécurité internationale ne me paraît pas
totalement aller de soi en revanche
j'apprends votre initiative sur une
organisation commune de la sécurité
civile en mditerranée et très
franchement je vous dis très honnêtement
ça me paraît une excellente idée
pourquoi parce que il y a une vraie
commonalité des défis et il y a quelque
chose qu'on appelle parfois la
diplomatie du tremblement de terre qui
marche qui marche de temps en temps qui
ne marche pas toujours on l'a vu
récemment à cause du fait de la tragédie
marocaine mais je je je pense que vous
mettez le doigt sur une initiative qui
très sincèrement me paraît sur le papier
extrêmement extrêmement intéressante euh
monsieur ti cher Jean-Louis alors il y a
jamais eu de pacte du Quincy le pacte du
Quincy ça n'existe pas c'est une légende
c'est l'équivalent d'une légende urbaine
dans la stratégie et les relations
internationales la rencontre du désert
pardon du désert oui mais il y a pas au
moment où le roi et le président se
rencontrent sur le bâtiment on est en 45
c'est une pari d'autres dans la
constitution d'une solide relation entre
l'Arabie Saoudite et les États-Unis mais
il y a jamais eu par ailleurs de
formalisation vous le savez
de de cette garantie de sécurité qui
n'existe pas que qui est dans les têtes
mais pas dans les textes et puisqu'on
puisqu'on s'est permis d'évoquer le
mariage catholique je crois c'est je
pense plutôt à à muta c'est dire le
moriage
temporaire qui est pratiqué encore dans
le monde dans le monde ch je pense que
une une analogie peut-être plus plus
appropriée moi ce qui me semble
intéressant c'est
que on manque toujours un peu de recul
sur ces affaires enfin on manque de
recul on oublie parfois un peu
l'histoire mais depuis 20 ans les
Saoudiens ont montré leur volonté d'être
très indépendant sur la fixation du prix
du baril les Américains n'ont jamais
fixé le prix du barol saoudien donc je
je crois que la question aujourd'hui
c'est de savoir si les débats en cours
sur l'obtention d'une réelle formelle
garantie de sécurité américaine à
l'Arabie Saoudite peut-être déconnecté
de la question
de du prix du baril voilà j'ai le
sentiment que c'est ces discussions sont
déconnecté aujourd'hui j'en suis pas
totalement certain mais est-ce qu'elles
peuvent l'être totalement c'est un vrai
sujet il y a un endroit où elles ne le
sauront pas c'est au Congrès des
États-Unis si la question vient à un
moment devant le
Congrès par ailleurs je partage je vous
l'avais dit ce je crois que nous sommes
d'accord sur le le futur militaire de la
Russie je ne vois pas de C enfin le
scénario le plus probable c'est quand
même une Russie qui dans 10 ans se sera
réarmée et aura pensé ses PLA militaires
je ne dis pas que c'est le seul mais ça
me paraîttre le le le plus probable
madame ligeman je je crois que la
culture stratégique européenne a déjà
commencé à changer euh l'abandon dans
les faits pas encore complètement dans
les têtes mais dans les faits de l'idée
du de la paix par le commerce et par le
rapprochement une idée chè aux Allemands
mais pas seulement l'acceptation du
rapport de force c'est quand même des
choses qui ont beaucoup qui sont
maintenant à mon sens assez profondément
inscrites dans dans le dans le logiciel
politique de de la plupart des
dirigeants européens y compris à
Bruxelles je crois que la vraie question
c'est de savoir si pour revenir sur ce
sur cette fameuse autonomie stratégique
peut-être n'avons-nous pas réussi encore
nous Français à persuader tout le monde
dans toutes les capitales que c'est
peut-être
avant tout non pas une question de
défense mais une question de technologie
de santé et une question qui concerne
bien bien d'utres des domaines nous
avons laissé nous français alors que le
Président de la République et vous-même
mesdames Messieurs les parlementaires et
les S tank mesdames Messieurs les sy
tank on a tous uvré pour montrer que
l'autonomie stratégique c'était un
principe qui n'était pas seulement lié à
la la défense mais je crois que parce
que c'est né avec la défense on a laissé
ancré en Europe cette idée que
l'autonomie stratégique c'est la France
qui veut séparer l'Europe des États-Unis
dans le domaine de la défense alors que
c'est pas simplement par rapport aux
États-Unis et que c'est pas simplement
dans le domaine de la défense et là je
crois qu'on a pas encore on n pas encore
réussi à changer les les visions en tout
cas pas partout de de notre discours sur
le sujet et malheureusement je crois
qu'il faudra une crise il faudra une
crise ça sera peut-être Trump ça sera
peut-être quelque chose d'autre mais le
le le seul avantage de la crise c'est
que nous serons intellectuellement et
politiquement nous Français davantage
prêts le jour venu à être leader dans ce
débat en Europe que le sont la plupart
de nos alliés euh je suis désolé je
pouir je vais pas pouvoir prendre les
questions sur l'Afrique parce que
j'avoue que je suis moins compétent sur
l'Afrique que certains de mes collègues
et donc j'ai pas forcément de plusvalue
madame pic sur sur l'Afrique subs je
préfère ne pas parler de tout pour êre
pour essayer d'être plus convaincant sur
sur ce dont je parle également désolé
monsieur monsieur Caran je terminerai
par deux points très rapide sur les
sanctions je crois qu'on là encore on
pourrait avoir un débat entier sur les
sanctions c'est avec vos collègues de
des Affaires étrangères également je
crois que les sanctions c'est c'est
c'est un sujet qui mérite ni excès
d'honneur ni indignité c'est trop
facilement c'est vrai la le le réflexe
et pas seulement en France surtout aux
États-Unis il y a un problème on
sanctionne je crois qu'il faut voir
l'efficacité des sanctions dans le long
terme que ce n'est pas parce que les
sanctions sont sont pas toujours
efficaces qu'il faut pas les les imposer
sinon on tnerait jamais les plouses
comme on dit c'est-à-dire que c'est pas
parce que la plouse va va repousser
qu'il faut pas la tendre je la la
métaphore est peut-être discutable mais
c'est comme ça qu'on qu'on évoque le
sujet dans dans certains pays et puis
surtout il faut pas négliger les
symboles en diplomatie il faut pas
négliger la dissuasion aussi parce que
quand on sanctionne un pays c'est aussi
en tout cas parfois pour en essayant de
de dissuader d'autres de s'engager sur
le même chemin donc ni rom Mira
ni inefficacité totale c'est des sujets
complexes qui méritent là encore un un
vrai débat et puis enfin tout dernier
point là en qu je je rejoins mes
collègues c'est pas une c'est pas une
complainte c'est plutôt un signal
d'alarme sur les moyens qui sont mis
dans les S tank à l'heure où nous
cherchons nous Français
nousous nous affirmons à avoir une
nouvelle fonction stratégique qui
s'appelle l'influence l'influence c'est
bien sûr l'exécutif c'est bien sûr vous
aussi Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires à travers la diplomatie
parlementaire vot V travaux vos visites
mais c'est aussi les sing Tang et quand
on voit la diminution de de nos moyens
et des des des subventions et des
marchés euh bah c'est quand même un
petit peu un petit peu inquiétant quand
on voit surtout d'ailleurs ce que font
la plupart de nos concurrents amis et
alliés à commencé d'ailleurs par
l'Allemagne merci beaucoup c'est la
première fois que je vois une voiture
écologique qui a plus d'endurance et
d'autonomie qu'une voiture classique il
nous reste donc 19 minutes pour cette
fin d'audition donc 5 minutes pour 5
questions 5 minutes pour mieur Boniface
et gomard et 4 minutes donc pour
monsieurprè la parole est à Jean-Michel
Jacques pour une durée d'un minute
Jean-Michel je ne vois plus la parole
est à Mélanie Temin pour une durée deun
minute merci monsieur le Président
messieurs merci pour vos propos je vais
essayer d'être rapide un récent rapport
de l'ONU rend compte de l'attrition des
CADES de l'État islamique avec une
espérance de vie de plus en plus courte
et également des capacités financières
significatives
diminué le 3 août dernier Abou alhusin
alassani alkurati prétendu calife de
l'État islamique est mort au cours d'une
opération menée par les services de
renseignement turc en Syrie suite à cet
événement un nouveau chef s'est vu
désigner comme son successeur peut-on
s'attendre suite à ce changement de chef
à des changements significatifs au sein
de l'État islamique cet état islamique
est-il en capacité de résurgence de
poursuivre son entreprise de
déstabilisation et enfin la menace à
l'égard de l'EUR de l'Europe est-elle
effective concrète notamment grâce au
redéploiement de l'État islamique dans
les pays d'Afrique où la présence
française recule je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Frédéric
bocaletti merci monsieur le Président
msieur les directeurs le retrait
pitoyable de notre ambassade et de nos
troupes du Niger semble donner raison
aux chercheurs qui analysent une perte
de terrain continue de la France en
Afrique mon groupe politique tient à
rappeler les sacrifices des militaires
français pour lutter contre le
terrorisme islamiste au Sahel et apaiser
les tensions ethniques et et
confessionnell exacerbé dans de nombreux
pays comme en Centrafrique il nous faut
néanmoins regarder avec lucidité la
situation le terrorisme reste au Sahel
et les mots endémiques de la corruption
des tensions interconfessionnelles et
ethnique ne saurait être réglé par la
seule force l'image de notre péri par
ailleurs demeure écorné et ce n'est pas
que la faute de la propagande russe le
président Macron proposait un changement
de paradigme dans la politique de la
France en Afrique on voit dans ce
domaine comme dans tant d'autres le
résultat déplorable au lieu de s'appuyer
sur le qu d'oré constitué d'experts et
de diplomates de grande qualité qu'il
méprise puisqu'il a supprimé leur corps
il a une nouvelle fois voulu gérer cet
épineux dossier seul avec le succès que
l'on peut constater aussi messieurs nous
serions très intéressés par votre regard
d'expert sur les points suivants le
scénario observé au Mali au Burkina Faso
et au nigerre peut-il se reproduire au
Tchad pourquoi une intervention de la
CDAO que la France aurait soutenu pour
établir le président Bassou n'a
finalement pas eu lieu et de manière
générale pour reprendre le titre deux de
vos confrères la France a-t-elle perdu
l'Afrique et sinon par quel moyen
retrouvera-t-elle son influence je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Aurélien
saintou merci merci monsieur le
Président merci messieur les directeurs
pour vos propos extrêmement
complémentaires quatre trois disons
trois questions que je vais essayer de
résumer ensuite par une d'abord quel est
le narratif c'est la question que
j'avais posé l'année dernière déjà quel
est le narratif français monsieur gomard
vous avez évoqué 2003 2015 qui sont des
scansions intéressantes mais on a
l'impression qu'en réalité le narratif
français s'est évaporé et en pour
illustrer cette idée je je pense au à la
la visite du président de la République
en Chine qui n'a finalement pas apporté
une un éclairage très net sur le sens de
la position française dans le monde la
deuxième question porte sur la cohérence
de l'Union européenne sont des questions
qu'on a un peu abordé mais par exemple
hier on auditionnait le ministre pour à
propos des exportations d'armement on se
rendait compte que 1 milliard d'euros
c'est le montant des livraisons
d'armement à la Grèce pays qui est en
train de d'essuer un important mouvement
social parce que là-bas on légalise le
travail à 78 he par semaine euh quel est
finalement le la dureté la solidité de
l'Union européenne la troisème question
elle porte sur ce que vous appeliez
l'endurance et la compétitivité monsieur
gomard et je m'interroge quand on voit
l'ensemble des services publics qui
faisaient la spécificité du modèle
français qui sont en train de
s'effondrer notamment l'enseignement
supérieur mais aussi la diplomatie et
les attaques économiques par exemple sur
atthos ou les
incohérences des partenariats
industriels dans le domaine de la
défense je pense au mgcs et je résume
l'ensemble de ces questions en me
demandant est-ce que la France n'est pas
prise aujourd'hui dans un réseau
d'alliances et de partenariat qui lui
serait structurellement défavorable
merci la parole est à Alexandra Martin
merci monsieur le Président merci
messieur monsieur gomard vous avez
évoqué le conflit nourri par
l'Azerbaïdjan contre l'Arménie comme un
probable défi
2023-2024 ça aurait déjà dû être un
anger fort dès la fin de l'année
dernière au moment de la violation du
cesser le feu et des règles internation
lorsqu'il y a eu des tirs à l'intérieur
même de la frontière rappelons-le
intangible de l'Arménie puis est venu le
blocage du couloir de la Chine pendant 9
mois et les événements de ces dernières
heures avec la rédition du haut Caraba
et aujourd'hui 28000 Arméniens qui sont
en train de quitter leur terre leur pays
pour moi il s'agit d'une véritable
épuration ethnique alors il faut
effectivement maintenant redouter la
suite et des assauts en Arménie euh il
est évident que les azérriis s'y
préparent depuis très longtemps menacent
entre autres la région du zangzour en ce
moment et force de constater aujourd'hui
qu'aucune sanction n'est véritablement
prononcée contre le dictateur alief ni
de la communauté internationale ni de
l'Europe ni de la France et pourtant les
enjeux ils sont forts ils sont
géopolitiques ils sont civilisationnels
ils sont humains alors comment
voyez-vous l'avenir dans cette région du
Caucase merci merci pour l'ensemble de
ces questions messieurs je vais devoir
faire appel à vos capacités de synthèse
pour essayer de répondre à ces questions
en 5 minutes chacuncord monsieur
Boniface vous avez la parole sur le
changement significatif de l'État je
vais prendre les deux questions les deux
premières questions qui concernent le
terrorisme et l'Afrique de l'Ouest en
fait il y a les problèmes structurels
qui nourissent le terrorisme et le
djihadisme et en il faut quand même
sous-évaluer la dimension religieuse
quand on regarde les motivations
d'engagement dans les groupes des katiba
les djihadistes la plupart c'est pour
avoir un statut c'est pour obtenir des
avantages et cetera et la moifation
religieuse n'est pas toujours la
première ceci étant on a beau éliminer
des chefs et ben l'adre repousse
toujours et tant que les problèmes
structurels d'accès au service public de
corruption ne seront pas là au Mali
l'état n'existait pas en dehors de
mamako il y avait pas de justice il y av
pas d'éducation et cetera et c'est tout
ça aussi qui fait que des gens
s'engagent dans des groupes qui sont
parfois des groupes de trafiquants des
fois des groupes criminels des fois des
groupes terroristes des fois fois des
groupes qui réunissent un peu les trois
activités et je pense que on peut
éliminer les têtes en fait le le corps
repousse tout tout le temps c'est pour
cela d'illeurs que on a échoué au Mali
en annonçant le grand objectif de guerre
contre le terrorisme évidemment les
problèmes se règlent pas par la seule
force effectivement il faut recréer les
services publics et que les citoyens se
sentent représentés en fait est-ce que
c'est un recul démocratique quand il y a
des coups d'État c'est quand même assez
frappant de voir des manifestations en
faveur des coups d'État moi dans mon
imaginaire j'ai 67 ans on manifeste
contre les coups d'État on manif donc
c'est quand même un petit problème de ce
qu'était ces soi-disant démocrati
monsieur saintou sur un typ français
j'ai beaucoup insisté dans ma
présentation sur cette vision the West
versus the rest là il y a un boulevard
pour la France c'est l'ADN de la France
de travailler à être à la fois
occidental et en contact avec le reste
c'est ce qu'on a fait toujours depuis le
début de la 5e République d'être à la
fois un pays occidental de ne pas être
résumé qu'à ce seul statut de pays
occidental et effectivement là il y a un
choix à faire entre est-ce qu'on doit
rechercher la cohérence ou la cohésion
européenne ou occidentale ou est-ce
qu'on tend pas des filets un peu plus
vers le Brésil vers tous ces pays moi je
trouve que c'était une bonne chose même
si on a beaucoup de rétisence par
rapport à ce qu'il fait en Inde d'avoir
monsieur maudi au 14 juillet le monde
est tel ce qu'il est il n'est pas tel ce
qu'on le souhaite et donc là la France a
avec les grands émergents une carte à
jouer j'ai dit c'est je pense que
c'était une erreur euh de ne pas être au
plus haut niveau de l'État pour
l'investiture de de Loula par exemple on
a fait beaucoup de choses dans le passé
France et Brésil il faudrait renouer
ceci sur le haut cararabak est-ce que
laannction de fait du haut-karabak
prélube une guerre contre l'Arménie on
ne peut pas l'exclure mais le
haut-karabak la souveraineté de
l'Arménie sur le GABA n'était pas
reconnu c'est pour cela d'ailleurs que
la Russie qui soutient l'Arménie même si
elle avait d'autres chafouettés et
qu'elle a pris des distances mais en
tous les cas dans l'accord de défense
entre la Russie et l'Arménie l'
haut-karaba ne faisait pas partie alors
euh en fait soit Aliel est intelligent
il empochche son bénéfice il ne cherche
pas à aller plus loin soit effectivement
broul tertr a dit c'est pas tellement
que ce n'est pas à nous de définir
l'intérêt national aée mais c'est à eux
de dire o jusqu'où ils peuvent gagner et
jusqu'où ils ne peuvent pas gagner et
c'est là donc où effectivement je crois
qu'il a empoché un gros bénéfice y
compris pour des raisons de d'opinion
Mme une dictature a quand même une
opinion publque interne s'il allait plus
loin il perdrait il peut siay aller plus
loin il perdra et donc c'est peut-être
là le frein par rapport et si paschinan
n'est pas allé défendre leokabak c'est
justement pour éviter qu'il y ait une
guerre qu'il saurait avoir perdu puisque
depuis 20 ans le rapport de force entre
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïjan a complètement
été modifié au profit du
dernier merci pour le respect du temps
de parole la parole est à Thomas gomard
merci monsieur le Président de je aussi
de de synthétiser de reprendre les les
réponses la première et je pense qu'on
aura l'occasion euh d'avoir de nombreux
échanges sur ce sujet sur la question de
de l'élargissement à l'Ukraine on
l'avait d'ailleurs entamé en juillet 2
2022 bon j'ai une position différente de
celle de de Pascal Boniface pour la
raison suivante c'est que je trouve que
l'argument de la corruption est un
argument pour tout dire assez facile
contte tenu de la situation en Ukraine
et que quand on observe la manière dont
la corruption
s'est construite en Ukraine on découvre
souvent la main russe et que la
corruption malheureusement ne se limite
pas du seulement à l'Ukraine il y a
d'autres pays européens où vers lesquels
on se tourne qui sont aussi euh très
très corrompus c'est pas du tout pour
minimiser le phénomène mais c'est pour
aussi à mon avis remettre les choses en
perspective je pense pas qu'on a une
réponse émotionnelle à l'Ukraine on a
une réponse au contraire stratégique
c'est-àdire qu'on voit la différence
entre un pays comme la Pologne qui est
intégré au structur euroatlantique alors
qui va avoir la dérive politique que
l'on sait euh aujourd'hui et donc les
ambitions qui sont les siennes euh de du
résultat pour un pays qui n'a pas été
intégré aux structur Atlantique comme
l'Ukraine le le l'économie polonaise et
l'économie ukrainienne sont comparables
en 1991 hein et on est dans des
situations aujourd'hui tout à fait
dissemblable et je pense que la réponse
n'est pas émotionnelle elle est au fond
dans la compréhension que ces pays dit
du voisinage euh sont euh cherch et en
particulier l'Ukraine compte tenu du de
ce qu'elle subit à sortir de l'influence
russe de l'influence russe historique et
notre débat sur l'élargissement à mon
avis il faut prendre garde de pas
l'ouvrir avec une sorte de nostalgie euh
d'une d'une Union européenne qui
s'ppelait pas comme ça à l'époque à 12
hein euh nous sommes déjà dans une Union
européenne euh euh élargie et je pense
que l'attitude française gagnerait à
être probablement pas euh
systématiquement défensive euh sur euh
sur ce sujet 2e euh élément de réponse
sur euh au fond le le comment essayer
d'améliorer les choses ma réponse est
assez simple en fait c'est tout
simplement de renvoyer à l'état de notre
appareil productif je crois qu'on a pas
bien mesuré aussi comment notre perte
d'influence s'explique à mon sens avant
tout par cette perte de substance
économique et commerciale alors après on
peut avoir un débat sur ce qu'il
faudrait faire mais la symétrie entre la
France et l'Allemagne au cours de la
dernière génération n'a cessé de se
creuser alors là c'est le moment des
Allemands d'avoir des sérieux problèmes
mais je pense qu'il faut quand même
intégrer je sais plus on est plus de 100
milliard de de de déficit commercial en
2022 100 milliards voilà donc produire
et instruire voilà comme comme début
d'un d'un d'un nouveau d'un nouveau
narratif maintenant pour finir de
manière synthétique je pense qu'on est à
la veille d'un questionnement assez
fondamental sur notre modèle
géopolitique parce que nous sommes face
à un rendement diplomatique décroissant
nous faisons nous avons en fait un
festival de sommet mais des coûts de
sécurité croissants et qui vont
continuer à s'accroître et je pense que
notre modèle géopolitique était branlé
sur au moins 5 fronts la Russie notre
politique russe a échoué comme celle du
général de Gaulle sétait fracassé sur le
coup de Prague l'Afrique francophone on
en a abondamment parlé c'est-à-dire que
nous avons aossillé entre sécuritisation
des régime et démocratisation sans au
fond en pensant pouvoir s'adapter au gré
des circonstances bon et l'IFRI a
produit une étude sur les la montée du
sentiment antif français en Afrique
avant l'été bon et bien dans les dans
les éléments qui qui réapparaissent
c'est pas tellement la question de la
colonisation qui surgit c'est
effectivement celle de la symétrie
militaire entre l'effet produit et la
présence militaire c'est la question du
du CFA et c'est la question aussi de la
manière dont les élites africaines sont
jugées par leurs propres opinions dans
leur rapport à la France troisème front
sur lequel notre modèle géopolitique
éitbranlé c'est la relation
franco-allemande et ça ça nous renvoie à
mon avis à une divergence qui avait
était apparu au moment du premier choc
pétrolier la réponse au premier choc
pétrolier de la France et de l'Allemagne
c'est le gaz soviétique pour l'Allemagne
et c'est le nucléaire pour la France au
fond ce choc énergétique que nous
subissons est en train de mettre à
nouveau en évidence l'orthogonalité
franco-allemande qui si elle n'est pas
surmontée en matière énergétique à mon
avis va va accélérer les les difficultés
de de l'Union européenne 4è point le
rapport à notre pays au pays du golf
c'est c'està-dire que nous avons depuis
45 l'habitude au fond pour simplifier au
outrance de prendre du pétrole et de
vendre des armes sauf que nous avons des
pays aujourd'hui qui s'autonomisent sur
le plan stratégique et qui veulent être
beaucoup beaucoup plus présent dans
notre propre
système et 5è 5è point la notion de
partenariat stratégique avec avec Lind
je partage la piste ouverte par Pascal
Boniface sur les grands émergents avec
toutefois une une une réserve c'est que
il y a plus une réunion publ à laquelle
je participe avec des collègues indiens
où la position de la France comme membre
du permanent du Conseil de sécurité
n'est pas remise en cause et donc il y a
là à mon avis aussi une posture qui va
être de plus en plus la notre
malheureusement défensive par rapport à
des grands partenaires stratégique et ça
nous conduit au 6e point je je pense que
nous avons un discours sur
l'universalisme qui est au fond inadapté
à la situation actuelle merci et enfin
la parole est à Bruno tertr
oui merci très rapidement sur deux
points seulement ceux que je connais un
petit peu mieux que les autres je
reviens sur le Caucase la question c'est
Ali serura-t-il s'arrêté l'appétit vient
en mangeant
malheureusement la la sagesse la raison
si j'ose dire devrait le faire conduire
à s'arrêter maintenant je suis pas sûr
que ça sera le cas deè point ou plutôt
une interrogation la Russie a-t-elle
perdu l'Arménie pour longtemps au moment
où l'Arménie active l'accord de sécurité
qu'il all lié à la Russie la Russie
répond absente et c'est important parce
que là on est à un moment où il y a une
offensive dans un secteur qui concerne
le territoire internationalement reconnu
de
l'Arménie le problème c'est qu'en même
temps la Russie est peut-être en train
de regagner la
geéorgie donc la géopolitique du Caucase
bouge beaucoup on s'intéresse beaucoup à
l'Arménie en France c'est très bien de
manière générale le Caucase est une
région à laquelle nous nous devons
encore davantage nous
intéresser je terminerai sur la France
je crois que le récit français alors
d'abord sur l'Inde c'est bon ça fait
quand même maintenant 20 ans que les
Indiens nous disent pourquoi vous êtes
au Conseil de sécurité pasanou on leur a
toujours dit moi je crois qu'il faut
être très à l'aise et surtout pas
défensif d'abord on n pas à défendre
notre siège notre siège il est là et
personne n le prendra bon euh premier
point deuxième point on est d'autant
plus à l'aise que on a toujours défendu
l'idée d'une réforme importante du mode
de fonctionnement conseil de de sécurité
je crois d'ailleurs que c'est souvent
quelque chose qu'il faut renvoyer au
pays dit du Sud global parce que
d'autres membres permanent du Conseil la
Chine en particulier ont une attitude
beaucoup moins alente et la Chine ne
veut pas entendre parler de l'un de
conseil de sécuritéin alors que nous on
a une position donc on peut faire du
judo là-dedans mais je crois qu'on n pas
du tout à être défensif sur ce sujet
même si on sera la question la la
question nous sera de plus en plus posée
mais elle était déjà posée il y a 10 ans
elle était posée il y a 20 ans
simplement euh les Indiens en 98 disent
on n pas pu rentrer au Conseil de
sécurité par la porte on rentrera par la
fenêtre avec avec nos ESS nucléaire ce
qui était une double erreur une double
erreur mais bon on va revenir sur ce
sujet maintenant on verra d'autres
débats je crois que le récit français il
a deux éléments de fragilité structurel
mais peut-être encore plus visible
aujourd'hui et je partage les
interrogations de mes collègues
premièrement à mon sens un décalage
entre la croyance en la magie du verbe
et la faiblesse des résultats concret
prs de Pnom Pen à l'Irak le deuxième
c'est une tension à laquelle il est très
difficile
de qu'il est très difficile de résoudre
entre notre rôle mondial parfaitement
légitime du fait not statut à l'ONU de
notsre dromecom de notre présence dans
le monde nos intérêts économiques notre
et notre engagement européen sincère est
profond et ça cette tension elle est
très très difficilement
résolu on voit d'ailleurs que on on la
voit souvent à l'œuvre très concrètement
quand on voit le à Pékin Madame Van
derlen et et Monsieur Macron traiter de
manière différente à dessin d'ailleurs
par les par les chinois mais cette
tension là elle est au cœur du problème
stratégique
français elle est extrêmement difficile
à résoudre si on pouvait peut-être
croire quand même un tout petit peu
moins la magie du verbe ça serait quand
même bien bien ben écoutez merci à tous
les trois pour cette audition éclairante
et utile pour relancer notre dynamique
de de travaux mes chers collègues nous
avons dû reporter l'audition du HECM
pour ceux qui ne participeront pas à la
visite de cet après-midi nous nous
retrouvons donc formellement la semaine
prochaine pour engager formellement
l'année 2 et lancer nos auditions sur le
projet de loi de finance 2024 bonne
journée à tous merci